salut femmes avec absolue tout le monde
fasse juste à temps 19h qui voit on
souffle sur le gong sur le gong à tanger
deux ordis donc je regardais sur le
transit que ça marche bien ça va femme
ça va ça va toi
bah écoute tranquille bien comme je
disais juste là on ait le temps de
parler dit seconde fusée nouvel ordi et
alors ils marchent mieux stordis
beaucoup mieux ré c'est beaucoup mieux
c'est vraiment bête a pu le petit bruit
pas si toi tu l'entends des bleus petit
bouc ouais tu as pu le nom du gaucher
ouais c'est plus un char est alors du
coup est-ce que c'est mieux non pas là
on ne sait pas alors attends je vais
juste un peu organisé ma fenêtre
tranquille parce qu'en fait on s'est
fait des cadres et au dernier moment à
la tête des joueurs juste pour expliquer
aux gens pourquoi c'est un peu la fin la
panique n'est pas la panique 1 on est
bien quoi mais on s'attend pas à voir un
aussi beau match que mardi ou si du coup
mardi c'était quand même trop ordinaire
alors je sais pas mardi surtout via le
suspense agréable là il y avait tout
mardi je crois mardi c'était c'est la
chante la cua ouais c'était quelque
chose
ouais darmon ça fait partie des matches
tu as peut-être dans quelques années si
tout devient champion du monde on s'en
rappellera de ce match là on s'est quand
même l'accueil qu'ils ont foncé il s'est
quand même on va dire révélé au grand
public dans un speech est quoi ouais
déjà premier match contre cariat kiné
puis l'a complètement quoi peut-être
l'année prochaine c'est nous qui allons
dreux
nous révéler quoi ils sont en retard
mais n'ont pas cette opportunité non pas
partie de son retard par un retard non
nordique unis du temps mais c'est juste
je m'inquiétais oui si inquiet que hier
à la mi-temps de lyon manchester city
que tu vas t'en su à renens web mobile
maps heureusement je sais pas où tu es
tu t'es dit tant mieux que lyon ait
gagné ça s est enfin du coup ils vont
penser qu'ils se qualifient en fait ils
vont tout perdre derrière et ils vont se
fatiguer pour la ligne 1 je ne sais pas
peut-être au mans tout cas c'est beau de
vouloir pardonner
tu reconnais tu reconnais quand même le
bas donc tu es tu étais joueur quoi t'es
sport gt pop rihanna est faux pas
reconnaître quand on tient exploite
feuilles d'une belle parcours sportif là
pour le coup c'est le club a fortiori
vraie force une belle victoire et
j'étais étonné un qui tiennent en
seconde période femme je ne te cache pas
que je pensais que ça allait revenir
surtout quand ils sont revenus à 2-1 et
belle performance
bon espérons qu'on ait une aussi belle
performance ce soir fab avec directement
une benoni une ouverture pas mal de la
vieille benoni fab ses anciens ces
ouvertures un petit peu oubliés comme ça
mais qui sont encore jouable et des
partis pas trop théorique non web où il
y en a comme d'habitude mais alors
l'idée c'est que les noirs ont bloqué le
centre bell dame
il veut les échelons leurs cases noires
seront faits tout s est aussi le maître
angers 5-1 jours et je veux un truc
stratégique voire pourquoi pas le jeu
sur le roi rebond est ce qu'avec les
blancs on aurait tendance à jouer un
petit coup que j'ai trois pour faire h4
le patron va voir ça mais là je crois
qu'il parte ph 5 du coût des clés noires
il va s'approcher de la case f430 très
fouillé son coeur c'est pour ça qu'il
s'est pas mis en chantier tôt dans cette
position fut enquête aux fab
bah ouais t'as l'horizon bouché pour
kung fu et comme cet homme aurait foutu
veut l'échanger
après bon ton flingue et d'autres jours
à des trucs comme f5 commerce mondial
mais du coup des deux îles vérité et je
pense que faire le plan marc en quoi
suis-je qui a aidé sa tête 6 kg 8
l'autre qu'ayant je souhaite est absente
de paris par un peu pour ce à quoi on
s'embarquait g7 j'avais vu un plan
marrant il faut une puissance de ce type
là mais bon là c'est plus possible c'est
de faire h5 trois sets carrés me f 6 kg
lui testé avec eux font fiant kétou il
faut h61 mais qualifie ce qui les usa
c'est très souvent dès lors il part pour
sa femme avait peut-être alors j'ai
quatre si on le laisse faire mille
lettres par france 3 je suis très sympa
qu'un plan de la paix un parti personne
ne peut s'asseoir à la table personne ça
soit à table on essaie city peut
s'asseoir à table
un f avait déjà je ne sais pas comment
je peux encore commenté avec soin a
coiffé d'un toit jeu je suis assis là je
me dis est-ce que je peux être assis ce
stream du coup mercredi et mardi je ne
sais pas et 1500 personnes qui étaient
assis avec nous pas enfin comment
comment faillite ils voient qu'on
comprend pourquoi n'y en a pas eu plus
sain et du coup je comprend aussi
pourquoi
des fois tu étais plus n'étaient plus
présents cités stream ont moins de moins
de spectateurs fab c'est sûrement parce
qu'en fait c'est ça ça prouve la qualité
quelque part mon nom fait référence
bah oui parce que qu'ils pouvaient
s'asseoir tu vois mais du coup je veux
c'est de la logique qu'on n'avait pas
battu à ça c'est un truc qu'on a compris
grâce à mohamed est né finalement voilà
voilà de base ces deux localités connues
du coup grosses qualités de guiry
d'ordre ils font toujours des pour la
fermeture marque et qu'on a fermé aux
échecs pas l'effort tournoi toujours du
toit fermé puisque qui peut s'asseoir à
à leur table quoi c'était faire ça en
fait c'est très logique un truc de base
dont 6 n ya pas de nouvelles têtes oui
mais bon mais enfin tu vois c'est de la
logique inversée
peut-être qu'un léger 8f six femmes
peut-être malheureusement à ce qu'on
pouvait prendre
mais en fait avec des blancs il va
vouloir enfin peut-être g4 d'accord
d'ivoire mgr caron des conjoints f5 en
tout cas secteur qui va nous faire le
fdf g4 pour ça de se donner la caisse de
cas du coup j'ai pas mal et noir qui va
nous faire un petit h 6 file string
toujours le même stratégie je prends ma
2b cavaliers étaient trop loin donné 6
mai blanc sont bien la langue est rien
ouais on joue logiquement il va tenter
d'envahir la colonne des fois on va voir
a pas de voitures beissat passé avant
que juste à foncer 8 et tu repars quand
alors le l'algorithme fab
ils pensent ils pensent que que j'y
arrive à tenir contre aronian mais quand
bullet aronian est plus fort mais je
pense que c'est
c'est n'importe quoi je pense jusqu'en
fait gris s'est fait un peu martyrisé
par mme amel année un franc en bullet il
partait avec avec pas mal d'avancé quand
même donc on sait pas quel point mon et
donc je pense que ben tu vois moi je
vois pas pourquoi guiry serez autant
mais non favori contre les vols en
bullet honnêtement fab il dit quoi je
sais plus exactement mais il pas content
quoi vraiment sur nous elle doit tout le
monde qui vaut plus rien wei du dob
en fait il se dit je veux plus personne
ne pouvait s'asseoir à ma table et tout
d'un coup ça c'est lui qui ne savait
plus à ce qu'il paraît et mono ce qui là
encore une tablette annoncée fini enfin
il va il se dit ce soir il a intérêt à
un toit à ce que ce que guy rippert
d'anglet qu'enfin il se dit bon hein
sinon je suis dans la merde je montre
mon expertise quoi sinon c'est un
minimum
ils vont peut être un as du rythme 2.0
je vais te remplacer grand remplacement
des algorithmes a fait très attention ça
peut arriver très vite
déjà ya le commodo qui se fait un peu
faim tu alpha 0 qui est là à deux
partout paal fans il a zéro là qu'il
faut l'algo de chasse point coptes
hadjar songe à ce point comme en sueur
quelque part non il fait défoncer je
leur a le goût ne comprends plus rien
raf
que faire quand bon vous demande ça
c'est pas ce même passer par nous mais
c'est pas fini a peut-être g5 encore
pour un tour b un g5 mais bon maintenant
tu as mauvais fourgon foot est offert
nul avec les blancs déjà propose parce
que s'arrêter final c'est pas jojo tu
lui qui trouve aronian beaucoup plus
fort des coûts tison exactement le même
lots fils donc vous êtes assez équilibré
j'imagine est-ce qu'on peut être fou
faveur guerrier h quatre cavaliers f5
bouffe le cavalier de mr vegas combat
d'avants le cas sont vent debout fait
défendre mais la dame prend
[Musique]
et donc là il tient les cases entre les
colonnes b mais du coup c'est clair
c'est blanc qui joue plutôt qu un
pendule maintenant aller n'auront
absolument aucun problème il faut
réaliser leurs objectifs stratégiques
ils ont plus grands volets flou ils sont
pas fayard ni sur la colonne béni sur
leur roi ni rien c'est de faire pousser
deux qui des deux est amené le roi quand
c'est un pas un mois qu'on est comme qui
a et b 2 des trucs je vois pas trop où
on va il veut peut-être je cavale et à 4
au suivant alors sur damas cinq escales
qui prendrait ça me prend à 609 6 et
c'est tout lâche en classe et à banias
nord ouest homs et ouais pourquoi pas
qu'il ya quatre écoutes femme qui est le
cadre d'un masque on arrive quoi après
peut-être qu'il veut se dire qu'il n'ya
pas beaucoup plus loin d'être fou clé 3g
c'est vrai qu'avec les blancs cela les
chantages ou erp sap aux objectifs
collectifs faut juste retenir la
position c'est un peu une fois 4 enfin
il y en a marre enfin nous avec les
normes très attristé énervé avec les
blancs ça très énervé à dire y'en a
marre je trouvais ou part d'amd sauf
peut-être damassine saponaire nous
aurions abandonné avec les planteurs je
ne veux pas jouer cette position ça ne
m'intéresse pas
c'est génial de faire ça en fait
d'abandonner comme un idiot que dans ton
truc d'arena peut-être oui je ne veux
pas souffrir ça n'intéresse pas les
gages je suis pas venu ici pour soutenir
aucun ouais j'sais pas ramène torrent c1
et puis bats toi afin esquivé changer
faire abstinence dans toute pêche jeune
homme se satisfont était mieux autant
tue-t-il presse un petit peu jeu qu'il a
été impressionné par les bonnes contrat
revenir et contrecarre ouanna mais le
truc c'est qu'à roanne en mythe c'est un
peu le taux palop 2.0 j'ai envie de dire
ça mais c'est vrai je suis faible en
dise pourquoi on ne sait pas mais bon
peut-être faire avec f6 un moment donné
mais bon je vois pas trop l'intérêt
normal ça se tenir avec les blancs t'as
pas trop longs tressés vite a dit à ses
quatre un poil fable durera pas si ça
peut attaquer toute façon c'est qu'une
faiblesse tu défends toujours une
faiblesse pour creed 2 faible soutien de
l'apce et puis qui rit quand même genre
que nous fans où on l'aurait perdu parce
que voilà mais peut-être moins plus que
toi d'ailleurs peut-être qu'ils auraient
tenu moi j'aurais perdu cela
par contre ce mec là tu vois mais toi tu
gagnes tu l'as pas quoi reste entourée
d'idiots d'extraordinaire en défense
enfin il ya pas eu un coût important ou
une décision importante à prendre
sapins sont pas toujours les mêmes pour
tout le monde même mais ce que je veux
arriver
non mais repasse devant tu as tu y es tu
si ça passe de l'autre côté qui ont un
très important à faire je sais pas pour
l'instant fait mes fils il va juste très
touché un truc c'est que moi je me
serais posé des milliers de questions
non mais il tire bien mais bon bref cij
a essayé de faire g5 mis la touche à
rien on est avec toi tu rentres pas avec
le roi pas de championne du coup tu
changes dans le cas où j'y suis comme ça
mais bon on d'études parlerait aux
cavaliers l'autre frère du roi b34
simple tasse on y voit des rats chier
c'est son nom mais déjà eu plusieurs ici
sa fille laurie j'ai plus de nul
aujourd'hui en dix minutes que iard en
deux heures avec mardi en deux heures un
artiste extraordinaire fréquents mais
rien à faire pas ça c'est nul ne les
intéressait pas que c'était pour un nul
le nul c'est un match qui restera
vraiment dans les annales mais a joué
peut-être faire piéger 5 est contré
enfin le pion à 5 maintenant un peu
faible à le cheap au maquis qui s'est
construit sa copie
mais après tout et fait roi prend
laisser le fou mathieu qu'ayant g5 et
photos dessins ou 3g 6 on va marcher car
cette fête qui est d'éduquer ses cadres
avant la finale de finale de rang ce
qu'elle tient celle là pour qui pour les
blancs la première vue non mais bon
maintenant il fait pas et ce qui fait
une forteresse médiévale iran c'est vrai
mais regarder de près en c3 il te bloque
toutes les castes d'entrée l'équipe l'om
ouais bah c'est portera sur
- carrément pas tim cahill venant il ya
mille ans c'est beau ça joli la
forteresse
quand il a trouvé ça et 40 secondes fab
solide un guirivoires ça commence fort
quand même fabre voyez la petite gaffe
mais ça commence fort avec la forteresse
donc pourquoi forteresse parce qu'en
fait on bloque le roi le roi peut pas
s'approcher sur les casques juin m en
rouge donc des cinq des katas 4 détente
pour toi le passage par ces saintes des
quatre mêmes florent aux trois débats de
promesses une cavale est ok mais est ce
que il pourra tenter ces trois pour ça
que l'initiation ils votent un peu et ce
qui peut tenter sa banque qui se gagnent
eux brabois rognon fausse et mythique
donc pas regarde des 3l à faire f 5 1
pas allez les blancs vers g35
s'échauffent à ben c'est bien joué ce
que kiev 5 pour le on peut pas va
falloir attendre que le roi se décale
mais il aura cavaliers f5 fgar ce
caprice fait qu'il est ici si ça peut
retourner quoi tout d'un coup un fou et
ça démarre fort un assez compliqué je
vais prendre à quatre sa perte de 6 je
pensais qu'ils allaient faire cavalier
f5 direct mais correctement c'est thomas
qui se passe pour les têtes se faire
brasser 3 maintenant on voit ces trois
voix des trois c'est génial à temps et
du coup tu dois faire à mes attentes
c'est pas mal il va prendre là avec le
fouet un carré mais du coup il fait rage
5 fois ses shows fab five on n'en peut
plus des ja sait on des gens sur leur
faim c'est génial que leurs noms mais
n'y a pas il ya paroisse huawei quick af
5010 france 4 on se prennent pour
chatons de 6 mai et ychoux voilà il
s'est proposé vous une à trois fois la
même pause n'ont pas de pouvoir mais
aussi quelle partie fab de sapins ils se
sont rendu coup pour coup un ouais ça
pouvait tourner elle savait pas trop
comment mais du coup un rosier vraiment
qu'à trouver coup ouais bah ils en
profitent peut-être un peu aussi du spi
de chaises pour pour parfaire un peu sa
prépa fabre est intéressant de jeu 4
c'est rafraîchissant du goût de changer
répertoire aussi pas cette rom motive
c'est travailler ce soir nouvelle
position et s'est du coup ça c'est
motivant en fait ça me changeait une
forte partie oui tu vois des gens et tu
vas des mêmes à l'analyse quand tu es
chez toi tu as des nouvelles choses
casse plus drôle bon faut du coup je
prends la bas-rhinoise enfin il est bon
bas-rhinoise pour la petrov ont toutes
les radios sur des cas tu trouves elle
anime zone du mas prend les salisiennes
tu te rends là grünfeld enfin faty quoi
que tu fasses en fait le tout le monde
te fais chier ton peu plus quoi qui fait
ces cas tu te prends les anglaises enfin
tu écoutais fate est tout le temps sur
ati donc ouais les vannes qui est bien
bien gagné son match de coupe dominguez
la de 960 il avait écrasé un on peut
dire que dominguez était vraiment su r
un fab notamment de bing est ce qu'ils
avaient vraiment souffert domine le
championnat contre une vélo ouais ouais
je chante là qui a eu du mal hein
on y jolie position de vendre des
changes la france adresse est vrai que
ça ressemble ça ressemble aussi aux
berlinois sein du coup la 905 mais c'est
dû mais la mode c'est la position
on voit très peu à bout et je sais parce
que jugée comme insipide mais j'ai vu
une victoire blanche dans ce truc dans
un truc qui ressemble et en regardant
des partis aujourd'hui hier mais je sais
plus qui s'était séparé est une vieille
partie de style it funky dans une
berlinoise qui est dans le match stanis
du caire torte possible le premier oui
at il répondu présent titre on se
donnait dix 81 kg voyez dodig origines
et où il a battu fleury il va pas jouer
de matches c'était une guerre tort
figurines une fois il a peut-être joué
deux fois sur carter aurait dû carte or
si un match officieux aussi du coup mais
il a bien dominé un steijns était bon
mais en fait vous pourrez re match du
caire lorsque j'ai commencé à regarder
et tout mais ils étaient menés enfin me
gagne la 1ère et puis après il a pris 4
ou 5 0 quand il se fait défoncer après
et ils ont changé d'endroit ils sont
partis de new york à saint louis à saint
louis il a regagné quoi mais c'est déjà
le signe et votre groupe à l'époque se
noue il est le seul de ce club avec les
archanges de sunwing
il était là non mais y était pas mal le
stalinisme et zouk et retarde pas si
mauvais en réalité un message on prétend
message n'est vraiment pas malin bah oui
doit-on se rend pas compte mais qui
parfois non mais vraiment aimé c'est il
n'avait aucune
lisez pas la même bagage que nous quoi
mais ils ont appris de leurs erreurs des
machins il inventait tous mais où carter
c'était super en sueur avec le c5 dans
le grand vide à bhl est très très
heureux de faire ces cinq jeux mais bon
par exemple s'il va utiliser le truc
c'est ça un peu fou soit enfin juste fou
et 7,5 fois dégage peu avant tout je
veux amener la clause partie où il fait
kg 3 kg deux échecs allait prendre trois
races encore dur était fou des six et
cinq pouces et 7
oui très heureux j'aurais ça y est je
suis ou 5 4 puis avait en soi est un
droit mais en fait sous carter dont je
paye se bat il fait des 4b 5b cbc mais
vain en gros il fait ça mais il file à
rien en fait là je connais très bien
c'est la française envers ses hôtes a
fermé comme en ont reparlé de ce truc et
du coup mais du coup il a quand même
réussi la partie d'après et a finalement
été complètement perdant et il a gagné
trois parties 3 avec les blancs genre
food et si c'est ce qu'on veut faire
plier pranger cents
j'ai peur que ce qu'on pense
bah ils ont joué des coups mais il est
parce qu il éprouve praxis et sirois
prend fou praxis ne pas faire preuve 5 6
kg à y prendre de mesures et de voir un
loyer fida match 6-3 j'ai eu des torts
g5 matin par cinq ans je suis obligé
cette foutue du mans sur après la
secousse de qualité si je prends le 5
mai et du coup les tn noir mais c'est
marrant quoi un truc pas mal hein comme
position intéressante répression ouais
bon on parlait pas trop vous comprendre
la joue pas mais c'est vrai que ça fait
double les pions mais je pense exprès un
staff je disais au tchad ce que c'est
une erreur
il s'en fiche en fait mais il nie les
rats tousart la colonne je suis contre
une tour dont il a eu l'occasion mais il
a pris la colonne centrale qui est très
importante dans la structure
il faut dominer la colonne attaque une
colonne ouverte il faut la dominer mon
avantage c'est assez
et du coup le plan extrêmement il prend
la case de 4 et de ce contrat qui les
liait et puis ok
donc c'est certes un petit pion faible
mais pire tu fais un petit roi j'aide
aussi a besoin moment dans les finales
ou quoi c'est pas très bien et bien vu
c'est un des pions doublé sur une aile
n'y a pas de majorité dont karin viard
et il juxtapose une colonne ouverte
aille très important ça paraît quand tu
joues constat pose apprêtez vous serez
juxtaposant quoi mais bon ce matin jeudi
quoique les blonds stationnement montage
ici concernant les noirs sont très
solides mettent un petit d'initiatives
dont je suis pas si laurent nous suit
d'ailleurs ce soir j'ai un peu parlé
alors en civil a du coup il peut nous
faire ainsi dans le chat est un conte
peut-être votre ne s'est pas caché mais
at-il un est logique
alors on ne sait plus quoi pour
rejoindre pour rejoindre l'équipe pour
ça un mois au moins d'être un génie
ultime comme carpaccio vote oui mais ont
quand même laurent bailly mairie qu'il
peut prétendre attendre car il a déjà
passé je salue laurent sentiers balisés
muji en dessous tu vas y c'est du monde
devrait un jour les boutiques comme un
fou il ne s'est pas bon g6 du coup les
cff 5,25 en pêche et peut-être que faire
fou g7 est heureux de réagencer jamais
quand tu dis ça je ferai agences
j'adore ce verbe s'agencer dans l'est je
trouve c'est beau comme verbe tuteuré
agences
je sais pas trop hein ce que bon ok je
sais pas mais j'aime bien je vais plutôt
recchi blanc si je vais perdre comme ça
mais c'est pas hyper ouvert cette voie
le cavaly qu'amélie pas si mal peut se
mettre au centre il ya des socles donc
durera bien j'aime bien ce soir c'est
bien avoir ramené le fou je pense se
fout il me paraissait un peu trop avancé
il vient germyn avec ceux ci dans le
tchad ils m'ont sorti risque du coup tu
réussit mieux à suivre sur twitter
depuis que tu n'utilises plus free parce
qu'en fait ils avaient des et des soucis
vitesse à venir de savenay de free mais
vous c'est bon là il n'aime pas trop
free et twitch je sais que ça n'est pas
toujours bonne bonjour mon ménage
mais bon après si tu as frittata tout
compris quoi donc aller où est ce que ça
veut dire qu'il parte si tu ne regardes
pas nos live tweet c'est que t'as tout
compris tu as peut-être je ne t'aime pas
mon jeu je ne perds pas mon temps avec
ses deux abrutis ça va on échange les
dames ont fait fou détroit fab
on se bat enfin parce qu'on reste on
peut échanger les dames et y mettre le
pion réussissent on va faire foot est
roi protéger la dame et je la finale
avec la structure comme ça où on peut se
marrer mais bouger la dame je vois pas
trop comment va vraiment qu'on va
progresser après ce enfants de la
colonie et peut-être on va essayer de
detroit 6 4 un moment mais bon faut
faire gaffe parce qu'après tout à fait
vide et 80 ans jean claude clark et ses
six fours g7 donc à voir mais moins
c'est une tentative pour voir la
position pour tfou toujours une bonne
idée de la part de foot bien sûr décidé
d'ouvrir le jeu parce que toutes ces
pièces longue portée donc jouer au
hockey je suis pas sûr que ce soit
spécialement réalisable ici mais
peut-être un moment et suçaient f4 tu
vas te prend 9 5 m il va être amené le
cas sur quatre sera le deuxième de trois
dont 4,4 pourquoi pas mais le problème
surtout c'est que ses hôtes ont poussé
le bleu marine et c'est de faire f5 et
tu vas d'essayer après deux refus
bien sûr je pense il est blanc a les f4
f5 pour le coup c
some petit accomplissement majeur
indique s'appuie encore là nul ça
rennais n'ont pas géré tu es quand même
content dans cette position avec les
blancs battait ça ils voient qu'ils
sautent puis tu attends une minute 24
secondes voilà faut faire plus attention
à kehl en implémentant pas vendre
faiblesse du fond de court quoi est un
genre de nadal tu fais tu es là socrates
et bernal à la tournée asiatique mais
vous n'étiez pas le truc de develop
djoko stone et moi j'aurais préféré
qu'il a achevé la tp pékin djoko a
personnellement apporté à bari chacun
ses intérêts il botte
il était bien pensé ce bateau bas il est
pas gagné 1 mais non non mais quoi qu'il
en soit il était malade
si tu ne gagnes pas c'était une belle
côte à côte à calmont son expertise
ouais mais djoko numéro un mondial en
début d'année alors qu'ils n'apprennent
pour toi ni revenant il a du mal à
revenir en fait gagner beaucoup
un milliard c'est à dire ok de nouveaux
joueurs après mam à mon idée c'est que
en fait personne ne s'était attendu au
retour de fédé tu as il était revenu en
force et je me suis pourquoi djoko
ferait pas pareil servi en force pas qui
peut lui parler tu as qui pouvaient
s'asseoir à sa table à part nadal
federer en fait c'est l'inversé
mais djoko trucks qui était déjà revenue
ce marché mal quoi il même soutenir m
après ça qu'il ya des articles
de presse qui était un peu inquiétant is
the witch au cou ne reviendra jamais ça
avait dit forget alors ok mais quand on
tourne entraîneur freddy aussi guy
forget il va faire des trucs dans la
position je sais dire a bien progressé
je veux dire après sur l'île forget
puisqu'il a essayé de mettre en sueur
dit ouais mais peut nous dire celle qui
est promu 6 non en fait juste à en début
de la saison et guy forget te dis avec
une telle blessure djokovic va peut-être
devoir arrêter sa carrière c'est quasi
sûr c'était quoi c'est le poignet
maintenant un slow food wayne kanye oui
on ne revient pas d'une telle blessure
on m'a fin donc je sais maintenant vous
opposez ça va être nul sa tendance
bromwich même s'il a bien quelque part
on voit passer en concurrente
cette partie c'est la même histoire je
crois qu'on passe pas en fait c'est un
genre de guide de carrière attend que
c'est quand même pas 10 ans rêve sans
qu'il n'y a pas accès fait accès à rien
sinon que deux parties suite on est le
même machin même genre de forteresse pas
la même tendance avec lecavalier a même
deux fois qui tient comme saga mais ok
pour l'instant où un rognon 2001
politique du match je trouve
ouais mais deux mines mais dominer n'est
pas gagner fab
non mais d'ailleurs faux marques dont tu
veux mais là on veut pas dire qu'il ait
raté bien enfin j'ai pas vu c'est juste
il pousse de pointe gris solide donc pas
petit cela va donc te guérit en fait ils
avaient deux cas les froces assez vite
ou pas ces 5 mai à te laisse pas les
mêmes positions
est ce que ces cinq est une sorte de
structure benoni sang-pyo un c4 et des
fois tu veux mettre un café il sut ce
qui est pas mal pour les blancs car à
l'ère du coup alors c'est toute la vente
c'est pas con le s'appelle en fait une
truc classique avec des principes wilson
donc c'est pas le met en boule attend
juste écrire l'appellation de check
point car il appelle sa défense la
variante moderne à la pine et tchèques
du goutte à cech grosse attaque
6 3 petits points à karaj et b17 week
end à un cra aux attaques quelque part
un nom précis connu ce serait très
précis quoi les mecs il l aimait que les
mecs ne connaissent pas le nombre
d'ouvertures qui joue quoi donc quelque
part sont ils se parlent georgia nouveau
km h et il faut l'avouer ebang distante
népalaise est bon et moi j'ai bien aimé
le cross attaque si tu veux cf
c'est quand même plus précis qua non bon
du coup je sais pas moi je joue pas trop
cette position je préférerais les blancs
lecomte a le sang entre un quart et un
peu d espace pour surveiller la crise
ses cinq missions qui va lire les place
assez chiant et en d3 très bien dressé
un c'est quoi notre plan à quesnoy pour
ne peut on avoir poussé pas je faisais
pas je j'aimerais vraiment pas jouer ça
qu'ils m'ont proposé un plan très simple
il nous montrait quelque chose même mais
moi c'est une première nous sommes
peut-être
et ça ce qui est un peu au bois debout
bah voilà des blancs et non des coussins
pour mettre les tours au centre elles
peuvent améliorer tranquille après vont
voir ce qu'ils font quoi qu'est-ce qui
jouons pour encaisser 5 cf 4 et 5
peut-être même on n'en serait pas là
dessus falun non non non non je pense
que je pense je pense que la fab faut
qu'on soit quand même très décente il
faut de la décence de steam et justes ne
nous ne nous prononcerons pas sur nos
stands d'associations en restant très
objective temps on va pas parler cette
partie du rang non mais je tu vois je
sens que c'est une partie piège tu vois
je sens qu'il ya une connerie à dire non
c'est pas on te lâche pas d'infos
championne de france qui nous surveille
mon propos mais un bonne chance présent
maintien de championne du coup tu vas
pas nous donner ton avis sur les échecs
féminin fab
c'est génial comme les ennemis qui fout
la merde j'ai regardé j'ai senti fab
pour prouver le plan québécois plutôt
contre 21 jours et rendre le truc mixte
je suis évidemment très content qualifie
qui joue c'est pas je peins d'hochfilzen
c'est pas ça le propos mais je voudrais
que les conditions soient soient mixtes
mais après ça ce débat juste mon avis
parce qu'ils ont aussi tout ça mais moi
je sais comment je ne débat pas tu me
connais serre que moi j'ai raison pour
un barbecue l'heure c'est vrai j'ai une
autre vision du débat si tu veux c'est
une vision plus tu ne propose pas que tu
imposes way d'air c'est un truc que
blaney beaucoup diront aussi suite à la
halla halla halla chansons de doc gynéco
en dieu avec renault hexagone il dit
vous dis pas je te le demande pas je te
le dis hexagone est en fait un duo avec
un jardin un duo avec un dogue j ai du
coup planer bien cette phrase quand tu y
es tu arrivé nulle en force
je te propose pas jeter impose quoi tant
mieux
ok donc l'eau sur magna quoi est ce qui
va nous mettre la tour on décide
finalement ces manoeuvres et rouge mais
tariq l'élan faut de tenter d'ouvrir
je sais pas un petit dessin qu'à un
moment mais il a bien joué son truc de
fou g5 machin il joue bien runyan faf
non bien sûr que payant l'art joue mal
j'ai dit tout à l'heure dans le vent le
dans la vidéo de présentation j'ai mis
une pièce j'ai mis une pièce sur guy en
fait peser des pièces à côté de moi je
t'ai les pièces mobiles
il y réussit il est pas mauvais les bois
il n'est pas mauvais c'est à surveiller
prometteur prometteur levon nos verres à
la gloire de l'est vont alors c'est
quand même des concessions ça non ben
non non je suis non non je sais pas tu
avais fait un officier se vouent mf4
bien je veux être à raison de quatre
mondes du coup on va pouvoir taquiner un
peu aussi attendre mais la dame est
truffé en plus la tour ronde les détours
qui sont plus ensemble sur la huitième
ça peut faire des prêts m un adjoint
chez base de bois je me tiens regarde
les dom est-ce que je mettrais zidane
prend cavaliers prends ça lui permet de
mettre l'euro f7 ouais mais là tant
qu'on rate intrus mais peut-être qu'il
verse 10 empêchant par là j'ai rien
compris là donc on propose se trouve ce
trop de nous parce que deux voyages sont
nets 1 5%
je pense qu'on y allant d'un tarif
seront fort cet ours est quelque chose
comme ça on est tellement nulle quoi
[ __ ] ces affiches ne le crois pas mais
problème c'est quand même la regarder
avec des visites gestion it ok il faut
un diplôme niveau évidemment un nul nul
nul
évidemment on voit moins vite que moi
bien
mary et adam h5 abandonné qui menacera
tour prend à 5 en force
on voit alors ok personne qui se redonne
ma caisse des 5 c'est pas bête du tout
bravo kg enfin comprendre mais du coup
quand même je pense que les noirs
souffrent tu nous l'as je suis un faux
nom mais depuis le début je dis que
j'aimerais parler dans cette partie
j'sais pas moi après les veines il a
bougé et tous on plonge de 5 est pas mal
mais du coup on voit que ça va mieux un
problème c'est qu'après tel tout faire
quand il a ramené à d'amendé 2,7 à
provoquer pts 6
et petit à petit tu vois c'est
maintenant tu as perdu un pion était sur
la pente descendante sur une mauvaise
pente
c'est un peu comme moi je vais en piste
rouge tu dis ouf a lyon des clusters m
ouais mais en fait j'ai des choses les
skis que je m'en fous ça ne m'intéresse
pas je passe par les bois mais j'avais
fait ça parce que je faisais du ski non
mais je des gt2 c'est un bas de deux
mois afin d'encore tu retournes à
expliquer mais moi votre personne
m'avait expliqué mais moi j'arrive et je
vous promets absolument pas ce qu'il
fallait faire que j'essaie de tourner
les pieds quoi mais alors qu'en fait
faux pas faut juste un québécois est
bloqué mais je me croise elle est ce
qu'il faut viser n'importe quoi c'est ma
journée à tomber c'est tellement pls des
bleus partout j'ai fini à pied quand
j'ai eu tellement marre rien que d'y
penser j'en avais déjà marre en fait non
mais j'ai eu super peur en fait là enfin
quand je suis tombé deux fois d'affilée
je tremblais et où j'en pouvais plus
qu'elle ne se retrouve complètement
bloqué au milieu de la piste comme un
débile
c'était une sensation horrible
maintenant quand on est trop vieux
vraiment sympa mais on a pris trop tard
du coup on se crispe en plus on met tant
du vin un mastering à la fois je savais
ce qu'il fallait que je fasse mais dès
que je me remettais j'arrive eiffage
avait peur en fait c'était c'était fini
mais les développeurs se finit donc tu
vois les gamins il fonce comme des fous
ils sont soutenus par petits casse qui
se bat comme le blond quoi ces dames
n'ont maintenant plus thomas qui nous
demandent stores moque
qu'est ce que vous pensez de l'autoroute
20 c'est très fort après est-ce que
c'est autorisé
bon espace colombienne laissions
toujours la même question
je roule à 6
je comprends rien à la fav sa mort
avocat il doit y les protègent de 600
fait mais non enfin c'est plutôt bien
joué c'était content de prendre un point
six semaines trop tôt à l'heure
actuellement mais qu'en plus tu as pas
de menaces caire bon tu es salaam
après s'élèveront quoi il fallait pas te
[ __ ] le bordel mais bon c'est
peut-être pas son fort et votre joie
puisque le joueur par gueye et complet
évidemment mais juste raté j que [ __ ]
le bordel quoi s'est pas battu anna k
non non c'est sûr mais bon il peut être
resourceful quoi ils le sont tous
avec évidemment les très bons tactique
et en dehors de la dame vers j-6 de
faire des petits machins
objectivement c'est vraiment foot us
matrix et que l'autre en face est aussi
bon en tactique c'est en fait ouais sur
pareil contre nous ça a fonctionné
puisque vous une fourchette je n'ai pas
vu ok qu'est ce que c'est madame prend
1,4 fois par exemple j'aurais
complètement ratée l'idée et suis assez
fou qui va rater aussi mais bon ce qui
est bien c'est que tu as de l'argent tu
as d'acheter un pion dans un four
d'autres plus bas prix ce que tu fais
tour f1 et ouais ouais mais tu sais que
tu pourras tu reprendras est fissurée
chèques dont je vois pas pourquoi il y
aura un chip ou quoi
saâdane compromis pour les noirs après
quoi dire alors c'est pousser beaucoup
se dessine et quads ont manqué première
victoire en victoire du match et guéric
ouvre le score donc tu vois peut-être du
jeu mais ouais non mais le départ chez
dominé non plus mais il est de première
c'est un peu les 26 qui pousse à lui l'a
fait deux fois ci forteresse et les
geeks et des veillées lingerie
opportunités il a frappé vraiment un
joueur complet hungry bon en défense ou
en attaque
jeanne ne faut pas l'oublier de ce long
temps qu'on doit mais il a pas 25 ans 25
aniche on est on est un peu parlé avec
lui il a du sens et pas les uns je crois
on regarde d'un peu de rap rendu n'est
pas leur truc c'est le seul le seul
drapeau tu fais pas un rectangle
ouais il est bon sauf à noël sans sapin
le moment on doit vous ce sera un sapin
pourquoi de noël n'ont juste pas un
sapin tout pourquoi il ya 24 tu vois
c'est bien c'est beau comme comité pas
certains drapeaux bio quoi dégage ça
rejoue la même variante oui oui il a
fait tous des trois meilleurs
j'ai toutes les jouer sa rencontre
contre duda il ya deux jours une fois
estompé et pourquoi passent en phase
avec le fou il est pas trop mal passé
sur cette diagonale évidemment quand on
regarde le roi de deux choses que kb24
souvent dans la pétrole ont fait des
quatre des cinq est à 124
donc il est bien placé après le défaut
c'est que les blancs qui font ces quatre
tout ça ils s'en prennent un peu au
centre mais bon wen d'ailleurs sur le
pense au match de duda et je me disais
duda qui a finalement tu vois a
posteriori il avait pris vraiment une
bonne décision en se remettant sur les
neiges dorff bas surtout dans le dans
les bulles est à la fin des trois
minutes mais c'était intelligent en fait
de faire ça évident à une belle lucidité
parce que si on était un petit peu
critique de base sur ce choix est
finalement là je dépends oui mais les
parents j'avais porté contre moi ce
n'était pas une grande et dès qu'ils
reviennent je voudrais d'abord vous
pourquoi
mais bon outil d'accueil match parce que
le bois je dis ça parce que le match
allait commencer première grande
victoire de sacha assez convaincante sur
une attaque terrestre ou qui a privé les
noirs où il a relève lancé une autre
sicilienne s'équiper attaquer à cette
fois mais il a fait son truc avec des
six aussi c'est un peu pareil scénario
classique et après d'entre eux étaient
hyper bien sachant qu'il a raté il a
même perdu cette partie là mais pas à
cause de l'ouverture justement et
patates ce moment-là d'assez bon ok
j'arrête je passe à la trappe
et ça avait plutôt bien marché tiana y
tenait un moment il est revenu sur ses
cigales et je sais toi motivation
bizarre ça marchait bien ton truc
pourquoi revenir après ok en bullet
toute façon c'est un autre jeu et de
nous attentions et à calculer très vite
et tout est bien en bullet donc pourquoi
pas pourquoi mais bon il est
impressionnant puisqu'il a dominé great
choqué car aikin tu vois et on est quand
même en droit les plus mauvaises choses
quand on devrait jouer béate en général
on est hyper hyper rationnelle non mais
duda franchement il m'a épaté
j'avais pas vu moi le match contre le
canadien
oui j'ai vu avec absalon cette belle
surprise avec ap sol tu m'avais dit que
en fait enfin son coup tu prends cette
série qui monte il ya plutôt des jouets
finalement après karékine ii très fort
que great choucas normalement blitz donc
non mais carl icahn avait un peu des
gens fait qu avec qui il a vraiment
dominé le match en réalité ce qui n'a
pas été le cas du gris tube non non du
tout c'était très sympa de leurs
éducateurs stress ces jeux la dernière
partie donc c'est non mais car iachini
l'aï la ville a beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup vendangé
bon alors revenons à nos moutons
qu'est ce que tu penses du loup en c5
joue le dans la bergerie
attention et puis on va sûrement envoyé
à quatre voies tout retaper un peu à
cette griffe et qualité celle pour
revenir et acquérir les savoirs acquis
la veille prendre quatre passes kaka et
des cinq quand même mais le far west de
nos lois 4 sur qui les destins croisés
de jeu plants sont ces importants ont
bloqué ce pion et qu'on ne va pas
enlever le flou ces dangereux criminels
oui donc il faut s'en occuper de l'avoir
à l'oeil si tu as aimé sourire où il
faudra bien sûr qu'on va prendre entre
la tour 3 recettes ou à 8 j'allais dire
aussi à vite possible ce que tu masqué
prend 1,4 maintenant vraiment exactement
je me pose est le meilleur c'est un peu
tout à part qualifié pour le défendre
maniche et 5
tu te vois donc tu as gagné un pion et
voire même mois alors qu'ils faisaient
un film tu te rends knk ypres en vain
mot que tu perds contre -4
alors attention quand même peut-être
mais non non je vois ce que tu penses
mais en fait non alors oui peut-être
septier prend 1,4 et prend 2,3 après tu
te prends des trucs mais bon les gens
qui réussissent à coup il est bloqué
d'abord fait surface qu'on regarde un
peu c'est de créer un cloud à jaked 5
comprend et j'en refais 5 pour général
c'est à gagner une pièce de personnes de
tous âges mais la vue qu'on fait tout
reprend tour
et puis en plus strict et les six
fourchette à la fin donc j'ai
l'impression qu'on peut le prendre mais
peut-être qu'on n'ait pas été apprécié
si on prend pour prendre conseil trsa tu
vas juste relevé le flou opinion un peu
plus dans les finales en plus sur le fou
est bien un jardin avec des pions serait
desalle vous savez c'est bien le foot du
pot cavalli même si le guerrier pas mal
alors tombe dix ans parce qu'on a loupé
en parle patois c'est hyper bizarre
parce que si quelqu'un voit dans le
chatt pourquoi quel point car ce marché
façon aveugle soit bon il a vu mieux
thiessois il veut juste après 6,6 en un
seul vêtement mais on est fier non plus
bien joué parce que tout est vide qui
est des six qui avaient si c'était
tourbe évident quand même et des tris et
4 après un tête-à-tête qui disent
assure-t-on v8 et du coup tours à huit
cavaliers bicis un bébé panda dsb 6 donc
à ce moment là je peux très bien
comprendre qu'elle a peu plus mes hôtes
et du coup écoute il insiste
sur son avantage parce qu'il ya une part
plus active qui allait se passer mieux
que les noirs blancs c5 et je dois me
leur faux pas de chance donc essayer de
ramener le couvert de 5 je pense c'est
fou j'ai un flash de de ses pattes la
presse il faut arrivant en le 5 ce sera
fini ouais mais bon ok je sais pas si on
va gagner c'est une grande question il
est mieux même appareil tout
qu'américains pions qu'il va faire bon
du coup dans ce genre tous et que vaut
mieux pas choquer valide pour pas se
reproduire nous dans les clous reposés
richie jen écart n y est pas ce que tu
peux échanger fou contre le cavalier par
contre 1,5 me non non je vais changer
les deux cavaliers
elle est confirmée je fais n'importe
quel échange de pièces poitou faucon peu
cavalier ou tout cas ils comptent le fou
ça va mais où le fou contre le fou oui
mais ça c'est plutôt ça peut quand même
arriver mon âme soeur qui tâtonne un
truc très très contrastée mais ok au
moins cette fois aux compotes de
forteresse qui nous rend va passer on va
très bien qu'ils la gagnent camion pour
récompenser comme son début de match -
revenir à égalité après ses trois
trophées au king est ce que guy rivard
retourner dans la petrov
la prochaine partie ou pas c'est une
question qu'on peut se poser
mais c'est vrai que mon attitude
souffrent chaque fruit puisque assure
deux parties ces deux fois qui souffre
et il devra aussi kiczek ses notes à la
mi-temps après ce qui peut aller vers
vers la nhsta off alors beaucoup de
choses je laverai ou 4 5x des siciliens
de signal
ça c'est intéressant à déficient en fait
je sais par contre à rognan d'ailleurs
moi j'irai plus sur des trucs comme ça
que du fer de 4,5 à 5 min et noir
la wii est peut-être lourd si ce n'est
pas tant que ça mais je veux dire il
faut s'appuyer nekoi rognons de 4,5
foetus il voulait déjà le 4e simple et
il est bien contraint glissé et en plus
ils en jouent plusieurs fin mai sur
ilsinho marshall comme tout le monde
mais
il a son dans me marchal qui maîtrise
très bien qu'ils jouent les espagnols
aussi avec les structures machin mais si
j'ai alors que les volumes ont déjà de
base les héros chance ça c'est clair je
crois qu'elle s'oppose bien fait
n'importe quoi à risques encourus
cavaliers f4v la finale opposait ça
m'inquiéterait deux chaunois n'y serait
pas ce qu on va quand même créé deux
pions passé on arrivera à faire un b3
ces quatre des cinq b3 assez car je suis
arrivé là bas en france et 5 mai en b 4
et puis et puis je ferai b3 et je
reviens de renverser sa relation passée
est fait d islam un cas de fourchette
dis moi non mais enfin la grc pire on y
vit encore les cavaliers mais ok
peut-être que bon c'est pire même temps
du contre jeu pour un beat fourchette et
non mais des fois on devine qu'il faut
pas prendre la décision de propres sont
parties lentes tu peux plus d'obtenir le
truc en étant très précis par déjà je
pense pas je pensais perdre en mai
envie de sauter autant garder le pied
pour des fourchettes évidemment mais tu
peux revenir attaque et b2 de faire des
trucs quelquefois pas faire juste ce qui
fait et donc balle c'est petit et blanc
font b3 après tu vas takebe 3 tu vas
essayer de provoquer b4 et après du coup
le 3 contre 2 fixée ouais mais bon il
fait froid 3 c'est très bien on s'en
fout été attaqués n'étaient pas
peut-être que de base va coûter au fait
qu'il y ait des 3 4 x 3 va d'ailleurs
pas de revenir avec eux qui ont des
trois et ils repartent avec son full hd
agent secret validé à michael 5
peut-être une touche à rien tu es royal
rouages et 7
tu laisses faire tes prend ses cadres
alors elle se soigne et portera donc à
-20 eu sûrement mais tu peux ramener
peut-être tu crois quand même vu des
conditions de froid des trois tu feras
ses quatre premiers et je sais pas si
elle vraiment forteresse mais en tout
cas clairement du tamis leurs chances de
survie est grandement ce que c'est bien
de vous souhaiter tôt converture s'il
fait beau
pourquoi pas enfin je peux faire après
enfin je veux dire ok ya un tas de
ruines avec ou quoi c'est jouable mais
je veux surtout le faire c'est les
ventes sont créés les trois tessinois
tito bien sauf qu'à trop quoi tu vas te
faire défoncer cap st enfin ouais donc
c'est bien
c'est bien sûr le truc c'est que si t'as
pas le carélien f3 il va te faire f 4k
relief 3 tu vas te mal me coller aux
transactions avec les blancs mais sur ce
qui nous attend
il n'y a pas faute et un échec eh ben tu
vois
du coup de pompe de trucs pour des
places à gagnon prise fou dessin là est
rodé l'un ou push ne peut quoi un petit
coup de tous les pions c'est sûrement
gagnant je veux dire mais
[Musique]
c'est pas sûr qu'il y avait 3 3 il vous
fait si ce nom ces quatre français 6 oui
mais permet long un nom très bien
demander 5
ok alors on voit quelqu'un heureux somme
définie mais qui ont traîné ses 17
reprises frisera des 5
c'est ça ça gagne pour les normes et on
va prendre les cinq grosses défenses de
neven enfin encore une fois à aniche fin
de nuit qu'est ce que je racontais
briser la caf 4 wii edition 12 ouvriers
avec les blancs finalement que jouable
est patent pour faire re 3d tranquille
et d'aucun lieu de mai c'est une sorte
d' anglaise de reading quoi ça c'est
très jouable
oui tout est jouable enfin alors ok donc
ça c'est une estonienne peut être une
sorte de benno nous avons 40 ans mardi
mais si les blancs vous à dessein qui
faisait aussi ses atours 8 bien passé ça
veut dire 7,5 le mystérieux même c'est
sa vie des livres et ça retombe 46 à
wales et le mardi on peut avoir de
tellement de trucs différents
alors parlons en accéléré tu peux
l'avoir par 10 par des anglaises par un
sorte de benoni où les banques n'ont pas
des saints qui étaient sur les rangs des
4 c'est une structure pendant beaucoup
de trucs
alors bon moi juste évidemment réel
atout réduite le sert pas à grand chose
pas si grave donc le plan des noirs ni
va essayer de faire à quatre mètres sont
créés en dix sept si l'échangé fructueux
se marre bien pour les noirs en général
vous fait ton plan avec les leurs en
gros c'est jack abry compte des fonds à
long terme
donc tu fait qu'il y ait des sept tués
changer de case noire et quand l'autre
de 300 clandestins que tuer bush et
après donc à vitry cases noires et c'est
ça ces genres sa base et qui joue très
bien ça et le pipeline est soit aussi
comme les vanneaux 4,5
mais ça c'est le mardi avec m
l'office des changes bon à moins que tu
arrives à prendre tu passes le 5 ou c5
en force mais la spa guerre des
communiqués en 17 mais voilà donc il
refuse c'est normal ça c'est bien tel
tour des 1 à 1 tour baa3 b4 live fr
ouais mais comme d'hab en fait il faut
faire un fait vigilants quand quand vous
avez un mardi sa sélection au crime
cible la pokémon 3,3 b4y qu il n'en
reste que mettre la pression sur ces 4
ou quoi alors quitte à avancer c'est
très bien su prendre les espaces et
c'est cool mais tu peux pas le faire
n'importe comment il a fait pour elle et
noir vont se ré agencer la culture et du
coup tu veux faire avec les blancs tu
mets ton qui en d5 effet eu des sureaux
set tu peut des fois tu écris leroy fer
être 80 là bas maintenant mais tu peux
attaquer 4 etc
et sinon il doit trois des quatre bons
plans aussi mais alors il fait aussi
ceux ci ça je connais un plan si tu me
le font au cinquième rang mais t'as pas
être quatre si tu prends ces trois tu
prend 1,4 et c'est dedans c'est adam
derache 4 tout ça et tu peux aussi jouer
f5 aussi toujours le fossé 6 mais en
fait du coût du jeu hâtif et crina assez
chiant ça ça n'a jamais choqué c'est
jouable pour tout le monde amène marche
parce que nous faire du dommage car il
va nous faire f 5 ou ce qu'il va
profiter à petits pas ok la marche 4
logique quand même donc je dis à tous
les trois parce que je crois tu pas très
loin de faire des trous partout sur
place non après on fait regarder quatre
perroquets évidemment tu verras un pion
mais tu confonds rage 3 vraie folie mais
du coup il va sûrement vouloir boucler
avec 4 et peut-être
maxwell et blanc j'ai pas il ya un truc
chang'e 3 fate of the gaza regarde
évidemment mais on a une fois dix ans et
l'a peut-être points 4 mais on attend
français cinq interviews mais va prendre
un premier lancé à l'assaut des noms
mais cette fois je pense qu'il a la
grinta était remarquable parce qu'on me
l'a comme ça s'est bien passé avec la
leur le 6 août 5 dommage qu'à 33 coup
c'était fini
étonnant d'avoir faire je crois quand
même même effet sur g3 réponse apparaît
que c'est quand même très très puissant
sur h3 ont pas du tout astronome
normalement qui a oui on a tout changé
trois que je sais pas mais je n'ai pas
du tout aimé faire j'aurais fonds
dernier dernier recours par ailleurs
décidé alors peut-être car la f4 froid
et froid avec l'idée de faire bouger un
kg torah ou un truc amusant mais bon
j'imagine mois perdus au 50m trouver un
truc mais il faut faire arnaquer
c'est tellement rêve que vous trouvez
des petites ressources des trucs et
chico s'il joue bien et qui minent notre
pays et les épis façon y'a pas de bons
conseils à donner dans la presse avoir
arnaqué c'est un art aussi un fable
enfermer la dame mais tu dois tenter un
pari ce que tu t'en doutes à y croire
l'un pour la f3 et tu ailles d'un coup
dit que j'aurais dit que sa pieuvre
bienvenue mais bon qui note tom cruise
de ressources des très fier de moi à
quoi là dessus ce même sens tu sens tout
mon talent en suisse quand il s'agit
d'armes à qui je suis là quoi allez-vous
gérer un autre jeu forcé des cinq ou six
pour faire flouer 4 mars à j'aimerais
qu'il y avait un truc pénible c'était g4
ou g2 après mes choix konaté dans le 4 3
mais petit muscle ronde
non mais tu m'en fous j'ai un rêve de là
peut-être d'hommes s'accroît aussi
confirmé la victime père mais bon on va
voir fois ce cap
ouais ouais on est des cinq ex jouer
quatre siècles doit partir avait
retrouvé autres c'est d'être bon bah je
ne peux pas y croire mais coûte 600
projets de normes et des 5 c'est très
bien joué femmes le 5e jeu propose à
chacun des trois chefs de renom bref de
maintenance mais fo h 4 mariages et 3
web au moins de mettre trois au sort
paraît turion 3 c'est foutu non mais
c'est vrai que soit foutu mais bon
c'était la salle ressources ne fallait
trouver des 5 1
donc ça il égalise mais ça joue vraiment
bien franchement du coup embêtant pour
gibbs qui s'est quand même
enfin il se fait un peu dominé de
partout pour l'instant mais bon point
pour lui ce qui n'est pas largué au
score non il n'est pas largué au score
mais les deux minutes partout non mais
la tournure oui des partis qui te sont
sandrine louit donc ces gens là une
variante moins intéressant donc c'est
pas grand chose avec le long pour un
poil mieux que deux tons chauds c2 et
bien et tu va regarder voler ton soutien
alors que les noces pas trop peur de
voir leur fille céline de base et de
deux ans tu prends la colonne
avant les noirs voilà c'est les tout
petits avantages très léger même leur
maître presser un peu ta 2 d'autant plus
quand on fait alors qu'ils changent un
but encore face à vannes aujourd'hui ces
cinq ans 8 bon après on touchera rien je
n'ai qu'à aller se former à dix les
matches ouais il va pas tarder à 9,8 aux
rites ou d'un losc en voiture bada
massatois dont tu vas te font du foot
trois coups pour lui tu vas me voir
souffrir mais elle est bien savoir pour
les blancs contre la petrov pourquoi non
là je me bats et peut être entrevoir
évidemment on est sûrement un truc qui
égalise ce soit mais ouais c'est agace
pas en force pourquoi pas le faire
peut-être que magnus peut faire ça
contre caruana d'ailleurs dans le match
mais aussi à laurent qui regarde nos
suggestions
c'est génial je pense que je peux leur
camp et donc pas ce qu'est un bon ou sur
bahreïn mais est ce que est ce qu'on ait
vu dans le camp dont il a du coup c'est
enfin on verra thème de la chute d'un
faux pas et nous non mais oui fait tu as
online je sais pas si c'est un bon choix
de pétrole
c'est un mini avantage qui te tourner
pendant des heures et des harkis et ça
pendant douze rondes
enfin pendant six du coup c'est épuisant
et mais que faire des jeunes de l'udps
ne tombe plus je sais pas s'il faut
avoir le sens de tout ce que je tu t'en
fous qu'on fait je m'en fous pas
spécialement compétents pour la dirco
jeune dame c'est le défi ultime que des
journalistes
c'est un peu le bal final du game donc
évidemment c'est dur quand tu joues est
une robe et en plus magnus disons même
s'il se casse les dents sur une
ouverture je sais pas il va pas faire
l'économie
kasparov contrat unique repartir contre
le berlin tout le temps d'attenté un peu
de changer dans cette insipide mais il a
trop trop trop voulu forcer ce verrou
cgr hilarité très énervé du berlin ouais
mais en fait je peux comprendre c'est
déjà cinq jours principe kasparov et à
l'époque la racine
non ces petites ouvertures est honni
miles amazigh qui joue un sale et pas au
coeur mais pas des pas des joueurs
d'élite vraiment de produits de premier
plan et est en fait ok les mecs qui
jouent cette ouverture qui je veux
sentant plutôt pas et qui tue le dira
qu'il fait et puis ont doublé et hors
glace c'est bien pour les banques c'est
sensé est venu ayant fait juste mon mba
compris mais jusqu'à un big bang où il
espère bien je vais la position est en
avance sur tout le monde mais il a
révolutionné quoi parle je suis
ouverture que ce soit et que baky sap
est racontée catalan avec plein de trucs
a toujours des idées
il a apporté vraiment la théorie mais
toujours est il qu ils vont kasparov je
peux comprendre 80 à te dire non mais ça
peut pas être bon ce truc je vais faire
accomplir par le défoncer pas mal et
qu'il a perdu il a perdu son titre mais
ce que dans l'esprit des gens il quand
même plus fort que cramique malgré la
perte du titre non bajeux non mais je
pense pas grave et que même si besoin
quel joueur enfin maintenant - voyez sur
la mairie au moment où il a perdu en
france en sept mois c'est poquelin est
impérial mais il joue assez petit
ce ticket trois c4 avec les blancs je
gagnais des sources portable phobie ne
s'en fait maintenant commune avis aussi
peut-être il a pu le la même précision
et que dans les parties de longues et où
il va moins bien convertir et d'ailleurs
en plus il a été malin il a ressorti le
jeu ils essayent maintenant vraiment
notre défense m
il fait un peu comme santoro avait fait
plus offensif
rappel santoro il avait une carrière au
début oui je voulais pas apprécié pas
comparer c'est un peu le même esprit et
commencé avec un jeu enfin été très
défensif et puis y'a dernier les
dernières saisons il a joué il envoyait
tout le temps quoi bein c'est une bonne
volée tour avec sa technique à demain de
partout grands traits c'est génial ça on
verra demain deux côtés
coup droit demain ça sera oui alors
qu'andrade bags je comprends pas moi
j'aime bien tâter des cours en norvège
faits et couper toutes les bananes enfin
la comédie de toucher des chiens c'est
sa fille qui pétait les plombs à chaque
fois ouais il arrête toi je mets donc
mais grammy gambadait aussi au début de
sa carrière il envoyait aussi il torée
les schistes nikos
on voyait des roses heures avec les
mains mais en fait ils ont tous envoyé
jeune je rappelle guy quand j'étais
gamin il envoyait aussi à fond sa brique
s'est un peu calmée mais c'est bien en
fait quand les jeunes n'en voyait pas à
josé partie chiante
je dirais pour t'amuser quand même de
battre et pour apprendre c'est cool mais
on sait bien tout envoyer même quand tu
es âgé pour corruption mais se dire un
moment les joueurs un peu moins fort qui
sont pas au dessus de 2007 chanson
qu'après avec l'âge il faut on a peur
mais peur de quoi au final en fait soit
au pire tu perds fac ce qu'on s'en fout
oui mais ça non mais en fait c'est
ridicule
l'album il nous aime beaucoup de mal à
répliquer oui je sais j'ai mal au moral
t on à pas on s'habille enfin comment
c'est plutôt bon signe parce que s'il y
aura un jour tu t'en fou c'est que ça va
plus mais je veux dire en fait oui c'est
une partie des fêtes
peut-être joie c'est hyper logique mois
donnant non mais je sais pas une tête le
jour où tu t'en fous chez oh tu reprends
du plaisir quand tu joues ce que je
représente par exemple toi
personnellement pour reprendre ton
exemple précis du coup tu es en sueur
mais est ce que tu es ce que tu es
vraiment heureux quand tu joues ouais je
sais papa ouais je devrais l'être plus -
de mettre la pression du résultat
en fait j'aurais peut-être mieux si tu
étais juste 28 juste pour le plaisir
était là
bon bah tu en vois ça passe ça passe ça
va se passe passe pas dans le besoin
j'aime bien les parties animées live cet
endroit tout le temps comme un non tu
fais qu envoyé quoi t'as plus rien à
faire tu envoies non notre mieux mais
c'est inconscient pas de je ne sais pas
je dirais aujourd'hui nos demandes et
notifie puis la simple on doit pas cette
pression à pense que tu as carpates gr
laderach ta chaise et que si tu en vois
pas tu n'as pas envoyé dans cette partie
calotte une petite cale au dr ta tête
allez bon stats en fait le secret d
échec s'il te faut car pas géré tâche
est ce que tout le temps bon écoute ar
de camions se passer dans cette partie
pour guiry parce que au moins il sait
pas autant dominé que dans la dernière
chanson un peu c'est la même structure
ce machin mais qu'elle dénonce et que tu
as lost et puis à 4 tout ça tourne et on
conçoit que l'audace et à ses choix il
peut peut-être faire prise prises et
après jouer avec du cavalier 4 qui est
des 3 1
enfin commencer par et si c'est la même
idée 1 et peut-être prendre au prochain
après alors répliqué avec quatre l'année
de 3 j'aime bien j'aime bien fab a mal
joué je ne prends pas pourquoi les noirs
c'est moins bien ici il n'y a pas de
raison
les items même mieux non je me sentais
deux hommes ceux-ci sont plus floues
même fou ces huit femmes par les fouines
et si on échange les deux mc les blancs
jarre sans cliquer f4 fraîcheur et trois
quarts et les pirates et b4g de meuse
entre en d3 ou de faire aux docks et les
trois fois mieux pour les noirs je pense
je serai bien 3,7 laïque et non pas toi
je me dis c'est la finale qui arrivent
ils vont réactiver mon roi
près de ton froid d'un match 5 du coup
c'est vrai que tu n'as pas tort mais
fouet ces huit là c'est l'autre couple
avait proposé juste avant c'est bien
rémi d2 tenu du fort c'est loin qu'une
décision de jordan ayew ce que tu veux
faire en fait c'est après je pense que
tu peux faire prise prises et j'y vois
aussi que les blancs ouais et g3 premier
tour pointent aussi jetteront et après
on repart sapia h 4 kg d'or ouais bon
pour une fois guéri domine et bien je
laisse la démagogie pas bien joué fou d
ici six mille empêche les idées avec des
cavaliers f4 qui arrive un jour sans
concession qui faisait plus grand chose
se fout on va avoir très bien vu de la
part de l'est vraiment déçu parce que
finalement tu arrives à faire caler f4
s'échange ce truc tu me confonds avec
4,3 cette femme même il a très bien vrai
ou si on prend très très très bien joué
de la part de l'être humain gauche tu
fais fouet f4 n'aura presque ça à gagner
mais bon déjà déjà ça a bien changé je
pensais qu'il était mal et voilà c'est
lui qui vous prend l'avantagé
tia l'avantagé un simple vêtement mais
on va tout prendre je sais pas il a
toujours fait changer tout ça je pensais
que ma eu le temps de faire du f-22
faire taureau un tour chez pas où ils
sont et cette colonie ans moins de
quatre enfants est deuxième problème
c'est pas aussi enfin c'est qu'il veut
faire peut être sept il y en a plus g4
moquer mais attention mais nous on
essaie de tout joueur
ah non mais bien jouer fou 17 6 blocs
qui va ramener le roi et du coup est-ce
que c'est pas nouveau les noirs qui
prétendent parler tirage et sa mère et
six à neuf autres capteurs heureuse que
fermer les flamands pas fou n'importe
autour de t shirts à s'en détourner
non je pense pas que vous êtes mal
écoutons avoir déjà bien bas pour
matériel tu es très heureux pas très au
point fort c'est juste non c'est cool la
cdc ont dégelé finale et des mêmes dix30
haché barça ça c'est très bon je dis
souvent aux cours qu'en fait c'étaient
surtout des six ya trouvé six la chante
là tu souvent à mes élèves complètement
talent fou de couleurs opposées les deux
joueurs une caisse de plus pensez pas au
bâton de tribun du mans a dit très
heureux de sa main gantée aussi je suis
très heureux de retrouver ça un jour je
pourrai le visage est toujours en quête
de plus je viens en fait c'est pas du
tout ce que j'ai en train de dire qu'il
nous a peut-être prendre qu'à moi même
si le sacre il veut il veut ça qu'est
allé au caire la droite reproche que je
vais vite c'est à ton pions des cas
restants ils sont déjà tu verras tu as
un choeur d'hommes armés joue plus vite
la riche que de tomber
ouais mais tourner le jeu à trois
centièmes ouais mais on avait 3 mais ils
jouent pas assez vite il est trop lent
tu es trop lent d'un maïs ouais mais
c'est pas fait encore peur noire des
trois jeunes hommes et 4 si tu peux non
encaissé quatre buts le propre de jaune
quatre chauffeurs web et trois tours je
peux vous allez encore faire
correspondre la fin puis c'est bon et
c'est quasi sûr ces gagnants mais ouais
enfin c'est moins sûr maintenant face
étaient gagnants ont donné
attaqué de toutes parts mais la tour est
mal placé la tourelle devait temps a
émis fin pour pouvoir défendre effect la
course on invite à ses filles tout en
reconnaissant être ici à tour été très
vite dès le début qu'il fallait faire
les échecs par devant peut-être ses yeux
oui la dépense comptable n'aura pas le
temps de venir d'autres fonctions
et donc voilà le guérin c'est quoi ces
papys senna tu peux montrer un peu de
fait les flashs banon mais l'autre
partie qui appartient à falun terminé à
6 la partie par le congrès du débrief à
la suite d'un procès n'a sur youtube ou
juste parce que tu vas tu prends un
livre naturel c'est pas on n'est pas
important pour lui c'est un non plus
allez bon donc guéri
ce que tu ailles jouer quatre fois du
match c'est ça se passe pas très bien
pour un nichoir pour le moment mais la
partie d'avant je pensais qu'il était
mieux peut-être encore rien compris mais
là tu avais une bonne pâte sa position
et finalement pas malheureux notre bonne
techniquement m à rognan au-dessus 1
pour le moment quand même dans ce match
fab
et bien pas toujours cool et donc ça une
partie de tableau qui nous intéresse
particulièrement fan c'est la partie de
maxime ouest ce match sera pour la
demande pas l'impression de passer
contre hikaru ce qui est pas fameux mais
pourquoi ce qui est loin d'être fait
même un jusqu'à quand jean maxime
souffre contre hikaru hype et garou qui
gagnent maintenant vraiment lui c'est
l'épouvantail du tournoi sans great
choqué et sans que personne qui joue pas
ouais mais
mais bon ok on va maxime simon femmes il
sera en plus en forme que les dernières
fois son omnia 7 un petit match je ne
sais pas où étaient crevés quoi ouais
mais il jouera il neigera mieux c'est
évident mais on espère en tout cas
non mais je te jure t sur genou lâche
une info quoi c'est une alien info qui
nous lâche ce soir je suis en forme
on lâche l'info et je dois dire que vous
avez laissé il ya quelqu'un alors qu'il
a fait remarquer sur sur le pré live de
mardi avait lâché une info en disant que
ce serait pas un beau match de toute
façon on ne sera pas très intéressant
c'est une grosse un match et l expertise
s'est lâché une info du style ouais mais
y'a le footeux ya machin allez je n'en
mets de base en fait j'étais dégoûté
ouais c'est ce qu utiliser ses doigts
façon doute un machin sera pas sera pas
super intéressant d un truc comme ça et
c'est l'info que ça a lâché le match de
bangui tube donc les bons la nouvelle
info maxime sera vraiment mon fort on
sera enfin toujours à mieux bon bah
écoute et on tente de nostradamus
seconde fois c'est génial que tu lâches
des infos de partout voilà face à un
afflux comme l'info n'est pas jugé bon
bah oui mais bon j'ai lâché l'info qua
non mais non mais de base retranché pas
qu'aux dates aussi bon bah je sais
qu'ils vont un kilomètre 40 peut-être ou
quoi mais je pensais que ce serait
tendre lilas et de deux je m'en fout
quoi et de cumuler ce mois c'est à dire
ça n'empêche le match était génial super
match ça c'est envoyé de partout c'est
que ça faisait je pense être un des
meilleurs moments des chèques de l'année
a vraiment qu'on a qu'on a vécu mardi
sérieuses et si quand tu vois cette
année mise à part les candidats puisque
les candidats c'est un petit peu hors
hors compétition puisqu'il a plus
d'enjeu et qu'on a du mal à comparer en
fait avec n'importe quel autre
compétition mais mises à part
mise à part sa saison je vois pas
d'autre voie que j'y pense mais c'était
vraiment le moment de
nokia comme quoi cette compétition qui
prend des galons fava on en parle petit
à petit mais ça c'est des moments dont
trois plus se rappeler que christine que
phil capoue tu vois on va s'en souvenir
parce qu'il ya plus de départage
peut-être mais c'est génial estime que
fish qu'après on peut reparler un
hommage rendu
j'étais tellement le cinéma la mauricie
j'hallucine et c'est un tel manque de
respect de la part des chômeurs par
rapport aux organisateurs et c'est un
tel écrasa les organisateurs de mettre
ce règlement je comprends que tu auras à
la presse l'organisateur je te force à
jouer et tant pis tu fais part fait très
fort enfin après ça de crédit clash
c'est chiant mais c'est la vie time et
ulysse et ma femme le truc c'est que tu
le signe quand même ton contrat quand tu
as aimé mon jardin non c'est un faux
tout sind sud se situe à venir en
contrats de travail à durée
je l'avais pas fait attention le mail a
dit oui on va écouter aux prud'hommes
c'est très intéressant parce que comme
argument non mais après le truc c'est
que bien sûr les gens ont un gros poids
et pour l'instant ils sont plus
importants que le club tourne il veut
dire vas tu au tennis
tapez d'art il ya pas de roland garros
est chiante un ex-haut là mais tu te
remettes s'arrêteront garros mr fillon
carson qui tout boycott et sénart
soussan fatwa de sartre assume que fils
et étroit des seconds couteaux et non je
comprends que les mecs ils n'osent pas
trop froisser non plus pas fin mai bah
on endormir de bosses tu oui tu signe
profane
non non c'est explicite de l'an on en
revient même truc fable c'est que comme
c'est un sport qui marche pas du tout
comme un business mais qui est vraiment
soi qui marche vraiment que avec des
fonds publics du coup c'est un peu lâche
anclades parfois trouvé beaucoup de
sections wildfire c'est du mécénat jaya
pas devenue une fan du rail jam et nike
qui est plus intéressant ça ça ou même
une marque informatique et une peinture
il ya personne qui est qu'est ce que je
veux dire meiway pour le coup enfin
c'est quand même hallucinant qu'après
plusieurs années il faut souci conneries
pour leur reprendre les commandes des
partages des alpha mais j'ai comme au
basket compliquée avec aragon pour
départager ces sait rien du tout juste
le temps d'une ligue mais il a déjà fait
des bills à londres la soutient quant à
me lever ali il est jeune guy en 2007 et
des partages à 3 et le bahaméen tu perds
la finale contre gaza
mais tu vois pour nous mais au foot
aussi c'est déjà arrivé il ya un match
de coupe du monde qui s'était jouée
s'attend à la pièce voient leur aussi en
italie aurait sasp et autres je pense t
italie argentine le match de coupe du
monde qui se jouera la pièce et c'est en
italie d'ailleurs ne se juge pas se
conclure ce sont dix pensent que ces
italiens rss t'as déjà c'est une force
que sa valeur au pérou les capitaines et
est parti ça allait jouer à la pièce
parce que coupe du monde et de salive ou
fait que lui seul de 90 mais la bande
organisée mais ce qu'ils ont déjà
regardé une fois non donc c'est pour ça
je pense que tu as été un héros et oui
c'est vrai ça va être conclu rss s'était
jouée la pièce et l'italie qui a gagné
ouais mais en plus ça s'est étiré la
pièce dans les vestiaires ok ok vas y
gagnent le plus beau chat soit ouverte à
patates à paleta pas les voir si on est
à un moment donné qui y mène est donc il
ya et le capitaine du coup il revient
sur la pelouse public il lève les bras
foulant bouillir c'est génial
j'étais beaucoup plus fort que l'autre
non mais tu me rejoins chiffon humide
c'était l'euro 68 pas pourquoi je
pensais que c'est cool du monde contre
l'argentine mais donc oui donc en fait
tout ça pour dire que le fait de jouer à
la pièce même si c'est un peu au bout
d'un moment quand a épuisé tous les
moyens de départage ses fins
bah oui bien obligés de donc j'ai
appareils pour la chine que phil cup
quand bien même tape tape à a mis assez
de 2,2 des partages possible au bout
d'un an ce qui suit i fé enfin genre tu
peux pas avoir il faut bien des parts à
loudun m'enfin tu vas me manquer taux
d'échec c'est très simple ça tu fais
jouer les mecs et s'ils font que des
nuls aux cartes ou à l'armée j'ai donc
cm et armageddon à trois pas évident
fable non mais j'ai fait juste
d'armageddon les uns contre les autres
tu vas fuir tous de venir
tu peux tu peux tu peux te retrouver
honnêtement alors là on était écrit sur
les caméras mais un cas de figure où tu
peux te retrouver à la mer se valent et
s'ils font que des nuls tu peux te
retrouver mal en fait c'est pour ça
qu'ils le font pas mais tu peux faire
jour un premier des partages et en cas
d'égalité
envoyez la pièce parce que là au bout
d'un moment tu as it dans le tournoi à
égalité et a été légalisé dans les
départage à la rigueur qui fasse un art
and armageddon tutu lance une pièce
parce que je veux dire si t'as pas
réussi à se départager en
en 20 parties c'est au même niveau bon
ben ok 101-102 les vols quoi ces caméras
qui ont bougé je vais pas regarder pour
le moment ce que je pense que ça va
revenir tout seul mais on va voir ce qui
avec les partis qui revenu c'est génial
quand on à surikate fantastique mais
beaucoup plus marrant éric guilbert
étaient présentes
il ressent le copieur mini aux dons
ouais un petit peu et tu as aussi pour
en venir avec avec le collectif tout ça
c'est vrai que le truc de masquer ou
cloud ouais du barça finalement ça joue
pas ce que tu sens que le psg s'est
passé pas mal non mais non ne sont pas
encore éliminés plus qu'alléchante non
mais ça fait des années qu'ils ont du
mal et tu sens qu'il n'y a pas une
institution derrière et je pense à ronda
mieux que moi je peux aller défendre
mais mais mais coûte navigué cette année
je sais pas qui a tapé à droite en
levant les bras sans surprise ou très
mal mais que ça va peut-être prendre
leur retraite contre une critique mais
en fait pas si horrible parce qu'ils
sont arrivés à garder leurs joueurs
ça fait un an que les maps à jouer
ensemble et even if à chebba ça peut
faire très mal pas j'ai pas eu de
chanter mais ne chante pas mais je veux
dire par là que c'est important d'en
d'avoir des institutions qui sont qui
sont puissants tu as lattes et la tp
pareil en fait c'est fort comme
institution pays s'organisent les
tournois et ils réussissent à malgré
l'absence tu as tu peux ne pas avoir
djoko machin en fait eu de trouble matin
des points à prendre donc tu es obligé
de venir faire les tournants au bout
d'un moment tu vas tu ne viens pas lu
votre équipe peut rien faire en fait bon
alors cette finale fab capoter cette
partie qua non ma cliente a plein cette
position se droguer pour les blancs mais
sûr je veux dire ça ça va être nul de
mon expertise
mais pour ce que tu sais pas c'est
bizarre c'est les droits sont un peu
faibles nature sera noir est plus fait
preuve
oui mais bon c'est une barre trop haute
la dame fatou vite te prendrais d'un
médecin alors est-ce qui va tenter du
d'amener un long temps de gameloft
question close où le bagne adore
pourquoi jansens même jour c'est une
erreur oui on sait pas mais en scène de
rita l'écran si ça recadre pas tout seul
on va le changer la gériatrie même pas
mort d'homme non je sais pas non non non
non nous de buddy méchants les demandes
de vendenheim et se déroulera à huy une
hausse de 9,5 qui changeait d'âme sinon
et la petite finale
mais bon ouais t'as ton était posé chez
asuka être précis mais je crois qu'il va
te cacher maria pagés 5,6 et clôt une
baguette et cloud et demain tu es juges
étrangers jean ici bon ça c'est beaucoup
plus marrant depuis qu'ils en tiennent à
l'écran fait un vrai j'en grande scène
est-ce que c'est bientôt la fin de
session me reste à 9 minutes et peut
être une ou deux portes hier cela fait
encore falloir cette partie est en
france et quatre non plus ouais mais
j'ai savouré cinq g5
j'ai cinq fables oui ça va mais oui
[Musique]
mesdames cette dame prend des 6e tour 5
oh la la il était de taille avec ça va
il a pris la fuite en il va tomber il va
tomber il va tomber c'est la chante
assez la chante là une souris il arrive
à jouer village il joue avec lui c'est à
vue il a ignoré si une seconde qu'il a
c'est le bagne adore il repart
incroyable fa village où il avait joué
lui restait même pas un quart de seconde
de rien quoi
je sens qu'à nice va le faire tomber ou
pas assez dur ça a dû avec la dame c'est
dur pour les vont aller il faut l'avoir
à l'expérience
alex de souza que annoncé leur regard
hagard ya ce qu'on valait d'année sous x
non mais allez patois mieux aller d'un
air froid assurant le pion et tu te bats
non mais fab ya trois fois la même pose
là et non le ton monte avec minutes tu
peux tomber même et géré la guerre il
fait n'importe quoi je suis né j'y vois
la mer monte vers ces trois années voilà
c'est bien c'est bien ce adams et 4 mm
es tu prêt budam c4 c5 je suggère faut
près move l'amant monneret mais je pense
que cette chose à perdre n'a que trois
noms d'amoureux trois sépales d'ars et 6
où je sais pas comment mais voilà mais
voilà il a gagné mais j'arrive à m'en
fallait tu sais quel échec chalet près
vous fallait arrêter de faire de faire
le moule ah bon il a gagné non mais je
m'énerve fab
désolé mais l'art est mort à petit feu
par monter un bouton ok de m
je ne commenterai pas cette information
voilà on va changer on va remettre les
caméras fab
alors là c'est pas évident voilà ça va
pas être évident de la remettre cette
caméra je te le dis mon fab
là on est mal fabing fabre on est hyper
mal de quoi que témoin ouais
non cette fois savoir fois qu'elles font
g4 ou donc ont prouvé qu'ils avaient les
jmj c'est la chanteuse avec les caméras
parce qu'il ya un mec qui est venu il
s'est barré il a décalé toutes les
caméras
non mais j'ai revoilà enfin gérard tu
gères tu es venu sur le live tu venu sur
le large à ce que je dis enfin tu ne
parles pas au vote peuvent contrôler une
fois doublé les pions mais c'est
peut-être pas c'est gratuit
du coup mais tu juxtapose je sais rien
franchement la fin qu'à lyon iii
j'imagine fab foutu là je suis un faux
bond
mam s'est spécialement structure quoi
c'est pas comme un bras cette transition
écho plus que je viens de faire pour
mettre la caméra
sérieusement si tu as même moi je me dis
c'est beau sur à ce niveau là je vois
j'ai développé je suis pas j'ai envie
d'hurler pop us depuis un moment et
c'est la première fois que je peux le
dire dans ce live mais mais franchement
tu vois là les gens ils ont rien vu qui
ont vu que du feu quoi re a franchement
fab 7 e bonds paraît là franchement j'ai
fait une transition de seniors là alors
alors alors écoute source structure d'un
blizzard va de soi que c'est pas simple
attaque et ses pions et de javel ça une
fois dans mon parti mais j'avais pas les
pieds aux oubliettes ne s'était pas
réveillée nue c'est pour ça que je vais
gagner cette partie détourné touareg ça
c'est ce que j'aime et ben ouais mais
j'ai vu des partis comme ça des fois on
passe c'est meilleur que ce à quoi ça
ressemble c'est meilleur que la gueule
que ça on va parler saint léon par les
phrases un peu plus simples et les gens
qui le risque rognage joue depuis un bar
à chicha
ah bon allégez lumière bleue derrière il
croque sont plafonnées à fond je crois
que la vie d'ailleurs à san sebastian et
si c'est pas rien une bien belle vie de
masquer mon club parce qu'ainsi ou
d'aller fabien c'est comme si j'étais
allé au stade anoeta
[Musique]
certains voudraient qu'ils auront été la
hauteur
c'est un bel endroit c'est un bel
endroit le pays basque ça c'est bien une
des meilleures villes d'espagne
c'est pas le même qui m'a évidemment
c'est au scénic mais c'est assez cool ou
pas très loin de biarritz a d'ailleurs
bah oui vous allez basque peut-être
qu'ils regardent ce stream femme est
peut-être ça a sonné par une ullah
dams et si on revient c'est solide en
dameuse est sa part de l'autre côté
pourquoi pas puisque maintenant il
provoque un peu tôt mais en kf1 kf5
c'est ça irina qui se fait une petite
danse de la tête
il est chaud patate bas il dansait avec
sa tête et gigoter criaient ils écoutent
du rap peut-être dodeline ouais bah il
chante là il est partout oui il est
heureux en fait il est qu'il écoute dit
gerry citation il a écrit il il soutient
que s'ils écoutent écouter très heureux
c'est enfin fait qu'ils soient dans ce
cas va peut-être damev cette fabrique
cavaliers h5 voiture est doublé les
pions jeannet double été pion kg une
miss qui est archi 6 qui avait fait 5 jo
famille il fait feu de tout bois
heureusement que l'on vous sur un
échiquier électronique alors peut-être
mis le feu dessus
ok ça va 4 pour les blancs mais oui
plutôt bien présent de travail
prosys évidemment pas renforcée des
structures plus on voit peut-être de
faire au cinquième jour des faits b5 et
finit 5e bien il il est il est remonté à
venir il est bien revenu à aniche
j'adore dans le conte souffre un peu au
début ça veut pas mon ce sont deux
machines émincer qui doit finalement car
[Musique]
je suis franchement je sais pas s'il ya
enfin hormis pour les blancs c'est pas
là
qui est ton favori d'ailleurs la fab
enfin c'était vrai que tu gagnes en fait
est ce que tu as à tarbes où je meurs
orient mais bon je sais que j'aurai tant
mieux pour lui mais je suis en mesure de
battre renom je suis plus pour hani
chehab celui tout de suite nous offre un
beau vainqueur
je veux qu'ils changent de réputation
j'en ai marre donc je me dis peut-être
tu vois que il se fait mieux voir aux
yeux du public en remportant quelques
matchs juste ci-dessus speech assure je
ne sais pas peut-être à forze j'adore il
aimait doit partir
machin non le soin qu'il souffre de sa
réputation après ses 14 mai le candidat
il ya cinq ans et trois ans et ça il ya
deux ans mais mais en fait le contenu
c'était peu insipide ont été souvent du
pape soit il a raté quelques gags ratés
fait il a raté deux très bonne position
et une chance j'aurais pu faire plus
trois en fait s'ils avaient complété en
maximiser son truc à fond après c'est
dur de maximiser c'est normal de pas
vers 100% content ému évidemment mais
bon j'aurais pu faire plus d'heures en
tout cas je n'ai mais dommage voilà bon
après droite sur d'autres occasions
c'est vrai que bon les candidats c'est
pas souvent dans ta vie si tu as des
occasions fauveau réparatrice était
candidat bien mais déjà ils n'ont plus
gagné
on voit bien à rognan quoi il ya l'air
quoi c'est peut-être pas dès la ceinture
de base mais cette année je tente ma
chance et c'est chaud quand tu joues
pour l'histoire quand tu joues le truc
comme ça donc candidat à l'autre à bonal
quoi c'est peut-être le tournoi le plus
du rafa sait peut-être même plusieurs
qu'un match de championnat du monde
c'est peut-être plus facile femme
l'année miser ses preuves en plus facile
de gagner le match que disqualifié mais
gagne le match super dur ce que matt
carle scènes du monde et tout mais faire
gagner les candidats tu dois pas te fuis
mec quelque part enfin cette mecque
pas même magnus ans il s'était qualifié
de justesse en usent les autres amoureux
c'est qu'on me donne de nombreuses mains
à londres des chroniques et des choix
aussi un grammy qui aurait pu gagner un
set facile à effet nul du coup de bâton
n'imagine pas car ça doit te perdre 10
de leurs équipements ouais mais bon
mais en fait ce que par sa psp2 cramique
il aurait fait une petite mine à 6 pi de
l'allemagne la partie était tellement
pas clair que c'est plus pour qu'elle
statue joue enfin nerveusement c'est dur
à gérer
trop dangereux pinceau qu'autre chose en
fait ighirri la fille est un pion il a
filé un pion sans faire exprès ces prix
de dames 7 propose un truc de fou je
voulais faire voyage soit zen prône
aussi ce qui est de me transmettre un
bon jack adam projet si tu veux tu faire
qu'est prononcée 3 tu prends la
fourchette est d'apprendre b s'incline
alors je pense qu'on n'est pas très
heureux non passé mais en fait du coup
c'est grave 1
je pense que moutarde des six nations se
faire dame ses limites à me prends mais
si on part des six du coup sa fille tout
est quasiment non stop un super truc
c'était bien là tu vas prendre des
meubles qui 5 et les trois îles vanille
reverser cinq 05 je sais pas où il va
sûrement à perdre alors que ouais il
était plutôt un peu mieux mais bon je
pense toutefois qu il est vrai qu'une
position pas qu'ils voient un peu noir
mais j'imagine nul normal c'est la
chante la totale ou six ans car je pense
qu'il veut tenter royal 7 comprend des
cadres d'un bep 5 avec l'idée que tu as
cette dame prend le portefeuille oui
c'est prévu mais d'un médecin qui va
rester d'un point de nom m
je prends rien
c'est bien petites scories dans le jeu
de ben ali qui a perdu son somptueux un
petit peu bêtement un nom peut être
caché comme truc sûrement fait surfer h5
donc je vais changer un premier qui ont
doublé et tu essayé de faire les 4 5 et
6 voilà c'est le plan est ce qu'on peut
y arriver je sais pas si tu veux faire
ça ou tu commences par le pion f à fond
et après le plein une pierre dalm 5 f 4
monte un peu le roi g4 ok ok ok nous
mettons ce que les finales de pions avec
actuelle serait fait quand même une info
importante à savoir mais là c'est sa fin
jugé sa déjà pense que tu peux être la
guinée film de pions en f1 tout allant
des tons orangés 5 et tu feras mais ça
s'est arrangé saint-hyacinthe you ça
mais je pense à une position au genre
d'avion f5 et le ronge et 5 aura
toujours le thème f6 peut-être free
d'envoyer ce problème est-ce qu'on peut
jouer d'un match 4 ouais mais adam
proche de damas trois alors ben non
mérite je pense après damage pas celle
là mais penses tu fais roigé 4 et 5 ont
fait très mal et un bilan fin ok je sais
pas quand on est obligé ou de cliff une
erreur aussi des fois ça ne marche pas
droit
iroise cinq mois d'un choix bouffe il
monte son roi tu viens au g4 tu fais 5
il ya trois ans c'est forcément mieux de
le faire avant tu fais quatre ils vont
être sotuver roi g5y mais c'est ce que
j'avais vu aussi et après ils votent
leur geste il s'est tu arrives soi même
s'ils avaient à croire que c'est à ce
moment là on va dire qui m'intéresse ce
sens à un moment donné on va bien voir
là puisque c'est très bien sur la wii à
temps à la battant le fameux rencontre
le 10 janvier là je crois que si ça se
passe c'était ça c'est gagnant ouest le
coup de réserve en plus en fait si le
roi reelement g4 elle était gagnant de
celle là je ne sais pas s'ils pouvaient
encore gagné en trois sets 6-4 3-6 oui
je sais mais même une autre preuve qu'on
voulait faire une marche encore même en
fait je connaissais la finale avec les
pions d4 d5
wife 6-3 6-3 et là tu dois essayer de
faire un espèce de truc avec le rang en
allant vers h5 sait plus comment ça
fonctionne ce truc qu'il voit non mais
c'est peut-être gagner aussi je pense
qu'elle est garde avec le pion à f4
aussi je fais juste voir g4 le paiement
retour pour la petite pause là il fait
la petite pause chance est gagnant dans
tous les cas parler du coût avantage
avantage aronian à la fin de ce premier
secteur puisqu'ils mènent
il mène 4-3 fin 4003 et demi je pense
c'est plutôt bon site pour les bonnes
leçons qu'il a un petit peu mieux joué
après c'est vrai que dans le contenu qui
rit est revenu mais cette gaffe dans la
dernière partie peut coûter cher en
avant la fin du premier tiers-temps
il reste le lead aronian qui est déjà un
petit peu un petit peu au-dessus niveau
contenu
je suis pas mega mega confiant pour pour
guy mais bon on pensait déjà d'un fois
qu'il est tout cas effet l'écart et
qu'il allait remporter le match et avec
la fin qu'on connaît donc ne nous avons
sont pas trop rien n'est fait et ça
reste ça reste compliqué ça reste à voir
ça ça continue ça joue quoi le retour de
fable qui va revenir à fable qui est de
retour va remettre le son de fab
autant j'ai remis les oreillettes jour
des bases du design du coup bah non mais
j'avais coupé tons sont aussi on
n'entendait pas non plus ce que tu
disais mais tu ne disait rien donc on
l'entendait pas forcément j'ai cette
dernière partie comme importante juste
avant avant le tir temps tu as un peu
comme au rugby quand tu passes une
pénalité avant la mi temps c'est quand
même heureux non bah oui cette mesure
ben tu passes une petite pénalité quoi
un point l'avant en mêlée vonn qui
domine légèrement le match quand même
ouais mais bon sans rien faire et puis
peut-être y lance qui s'accélère ce sera
plutôt un taux de guérison lancerait en
photo six ans et la fin d'après le
l'algorithme celle inverse
mais bon je suis pas convaincu je pense
que l'algorithme il se fait il se fait
vraiment piéger par
[Musique]
par le match de mah mais contre guiry
sanou plus intelligent que le que
l'algorithme et les rebelles zaïdites et
bientôt femmes marseille qui est en
train de se faire surprendre par
francfort
non mais par contre à vélodrome ouais
mais bon il joue à dix contre onze quand
même un bon vous en dise c'est la
fanfare et et 10 mars a été la gare
taillon 11 mars et gilles bâillât
jovovich là je suis en train de voir
90e minute et bien de marquer l'habitude
de messages ou en huit lots pas de pas
de pas de public vont après quand tu
vois les stats c'est 20 tirs pour
marseille contre 9 donc ils ont ils ont
ils ont pareillement dominé le match
mais dominer n'est pas gagner on dit
qu'il va y avoir une télé de moins pour
mouvaux d'avril à la télé va y passer
fab avec c'est dommage quand tu as le
meilleur attaquant d'europe me trouble
où est mon meilleur attaquant d'europe
donc devant messi fab mais je sais pas s
qui jouait déjà mitt romney mais
mitroglou jouais pas aussi fab pas
forcément non je te passe toto star
allez on nous empêche de valère germain
donc allez on
reckitt il te manquer m il est rentré
mitroglou j'écoute a dit hu a égalisé
fab
je les regarde un peu semblent du coup
sa petite europe en ligne j'arrive pas 3
mumbai et pour l'europa league
c'est reparti fab pour les speechs à ce
dur mais oui dans les clubs allemands
sont très forts mba j'aime me mettre en
jambes ce cas non pas de sept fois plus
lourd soit un truc pays de l' east 1
jablonec la fameuse ville de jablonec
fab
enfin la jeanne d'arc ok ok ok bah
écoute c'est reparti c'est en partie
mais oui pour l'europa league le
problème en fait c'est qu'il sait que
avec des champions contre l'importance
du coup tu te prends d'aujourd'hui des
champions et des grosses affiches
et puis après tu as marqué qu'une fois
en face à deux balles assez sympa mais
bon alléchant alors que ce serait dans
l'autre sens peut-être mieux je commence
par marseille francfort le mardi je
crois que c'est étudié fabre en fait les
soirées du mardi mercredi tout ça je
crois que c'est une niche pic à plus de
monde qui croient que je dis c'est un
peu la soirée étudiante serait en sueur
ouais tu as aimé même vendredi samedi
soir c'est pas forcément le top ont fait
ce choix mardi et mercredi c'est lé
meilleur jour d'accord mais je viens
voir mais ce que je veux dire c'est que
si jamais ça c est pas ça juste de bages
trouvera sa plongée de queen à paris
après ça nous donne son appui franc le
après fait c'est un peu comme si on
speech est avait un guerrier aronian
comme ce soir et puis que le mardi tu
avais des seconds couteaux qui joues et
tu as trois jours d'affilée dans tous
les cas mon avis tu oses après études
après le premier match et mon
intéressant mais la femme dans cette
partie c'est important pour guérir mon
avis de oued gros coup en direct alors
qu aux dires de recoller au score
directement ou de j'aime bien sa
position
peut-être qu'ils résident que parler de
maiko avec du dam g2g 4 plus agressif
adapter une quoi ce truc
mathieu met également à profit sa
vitesse tue à répéter une fois moi je
pensais que c'était trois compagnies
donc il répète quoi ya pas de problème
qui va remettre le quai des arts trois
mêmes c'est bien c'est avec 4 après tu
faire h4 fuji son coaching aussi
d'ailleurs
parce que quand tu y arrives en 3g 4 car
il faut faire gaffe de ne pas se prendre
g5 quand même cette dame de trois ans
compte du fossé sépare dame de ne pas
bouger gâte empêche aussi g5 1 femme une
attaque le pays en plus un tacle aux
cavaliers aux caisses desjardins me 6,1
et dames de la main ils échangent
beaucoup de finale quand même
aujourd'hui deux finalités gloire et
donc mance de jean ferrat rêve prend
mais du coup ça utile dans la mesure
était central après 4 je pensais très
bien joué
ouais mais c'est dur à prendre qu'on
décide ou pas je veux dire bien sûr fin
en blitz aussi vite ma chance c'est
beaucoup c'est très très nerveux
je trouve pas que c'est très très bien
joué de la part de delémont et les
ventes qui se dirige avec le carrier
verser 3 qui a peut-être fait repousser
cinq et shaq fu de 4,7 entre les bons
qui non non non je sais pas où je les
dis tu auras à 3 pts et 4 mais je passe
il fait quand même mais bekkat pas si
bon de cette tourbe et 3 bêtement ses
cinq nuits sans qu'on se fixe ne vous
croient pas à ce que ces seigneurs du 6
cas les vannes qui a des questions à
contre décati foutront les 4 et 5 de ça
va mais quatre moutons de notre journal
écrit encore le voir alors du coup du
coup de tête c'est 1 500 auxquels on
peut faire caler prend pour prendre pour
en [ __ ] ans je passe mon âme et
bresnick les deux et après on balance
ses quatre et on veut faire tourner vite
je sais pas ça se regarde regarde ceux
percevant même pourquoi pas même privé
si ce père a joué dans le sens où tu ne
la connais pas ton va deux modes ce sont
tes bons et plus font des quatre comme
celle provenant un essai fini au
vélodrome est bon à prendre et c6 et la
sphère tour est-ce qu'on fait tourbe et
de femmes pour arrimer tournée qu'il ya
quatre peut-être mais surtout rassuré
qu'il prend ces trois jours et bien à 2
le scénario des partis c'est comme les
vannes qui réussit à stratégiquement et
un poil au dessus
il est impressionnant les vannes ce soir
vous aurez tout motif outremont et c2 du
coup pour colmater un peu tout ça je
suis plus impressionné par les bonnes ce
soir que par les bonnes contre contre
fabiano étonnant ils font nulle part
ouais ouais je reste très nerveux en
tête que c'est plus visuel d'autre chose
on s'aime mais ses contempteurs soit
rangé tout ça mais bon ok bon et pas mal
à rognan comme de base jeu mais bien peu
sont guéris le coup et a retourné le
truc c'est peut-être la dame trois sites
silva et du soin sous estimé françois
bon peut-être qu'on peut pas faire mieux
que septième papa pensée f
ce qui me frappe c'est ça on n'a pas été
numéro 2 mondial pour rien
bonjour storni hockey fun
je connais trop ce que c'est
impressionnant seedorf et ce switch vers
eux quatre femmes est de réussir à
dominer a dominé avec les blancs dans la
petrov c'est je trouve que c'est aussi
un tour de force de la part baroin jan
fabre est ça qui se fait passer chez la
position rien n'arrive à petit du jeu
sans être un joueur 2,4 de base
ils font un lieu de switcher à quelques
mois il réussit déjà à régler les
problèmes les plus les plus difficiles
sur l'ouverture
c'est une mort après donc et ces joueurs
là toute façon il peut toujours se dire
une telle culture il connaît tout un
pays d'à mans était beaucoup plus
spécialisés dans les autres au lieu
d'avoir des prépas enfin c'est sur mon
nom il est connu aussi pour ses grosses
prépa mais une erreur est ok il connaît
depuis longtemps je veux c'est sur mais
bon ça reste impressionnant quand même
mais bon même si koné il joue contre les
mecs qui connaissent très bien donc
c'est c'est bon
donc cette tour alain minc et h 4 kf5
peut-être un jour
ouais mais c'est toujours la même
histoire en fait il ya pas grand chose
mais comme je disais tu t'occupes un peu
mieux la balle à cologne ouest et
cavalli son nuage en sait un peu mieux
agencé ok d'étranges c'est simple
peut-être d'autres jeux comme the beer
store
ouais carter t'améliorer le fou en f4
qui pourrait venir pour nous un peu
comme un système de londres tu as qui
élu domicile se libère le fouet fcaata
tu as peut-être la c5 cure mais le foie
f4 tu veux un jour du système de l'undd
avec le fou de cases noires qui domine
un peu le petit cube et 4 4 2 ou wii
voici qu'un autre se sont taris que la
niche aurait pas l'intérêt fab a changé
d'ouverture notez quand même une âge
d'or parce qu'il s'entête dans cette
petrov et ouais franchement je ne sais
pas ce que j'aimerais bien voir des
cityens ce que je te dise a remis en jeu
j'aimerais bien faire autre chose que 4
500 qui s'entête dans cette petrov et il
est toujours un peu moins bien et même
si il perd pas hyper de l'influx nerveux
fab dans ces parties à force de défendre
est ce que tu vois des fois on oui mais
bon on a tué jury mais bon tu ne perds
pas tu tiens mais c'est parti laisse
quand même des plumes
à force de défendre notre essai des
plumes qui peuvent te manquer et on nous
fait des plumes qui écoutent même par
les oiseaux fab 7 pts éléments ont
préparé à 4 c 5 ça être méchant et après
b 4 des 5
je vais peut-être ces cinq pour éviter
l'écueil b5 qui sait peut-être à sa 4
pardon pour commencer
mais ça se laisse pas fixée j'aime bien
ce coup femmes les cinq doigts ces
responsables parce que ok si on se
choisit de faire ces cinq équipes mais
on va quand même une rupture à 4 un jour
il va pas choisi de faire c'est ça qu'il
ait changé mais c'est pas mal que toi
parce que tu l'as bien le coin avec la
carte y aurait peut-être eu des quatre à
cinq mules voit bien je mets bien
j'imagine on peut peut-être le préparer
ok peut-être talent et d injuste de
faire à 5
comment les slaves un peu et après tu
fermes et d'un côté de l'autre
bon mais il joue colonnes c'est manon
mais il a raison de faire ça permet du
coup il a raison est-ce qu'on compare
avec du cavalier à 6 pour essayer de se
ré agencer fait p 4 mais il a ce qu à
quatre et c5 fab bon pays qui
réussissent
c'est un jeu de manoeuvre fable à sanaa
ce qui est 4e vite et maintenant il va
vous la rentrée saddam dame assise d'un
médecin donc il donne à 6 c'est bien
mais je veux qu'on parle de l'autre côté
peut-être vers f5 et passionnant des
trois à six étaient idéales on a pu
peut-être qu'il va risquer son cahier 03
kf1 qui est de fait inquiète les deux
cas les freins qui a lieu trois qui
serait d'un gaz oil qui vient du taux
taxe ne peut décemment
mais bon les noirs ils vont aussi
peut-être de servier me replacer le flou
grasset touché papote les idées 4 pas
évident à faire parce que tu tombes
palais de pouce pour l'instant
dames c6r jouer je pense à moi mais une
fois j'aimerais vendre c'est pas énorme
comment t'as pas compris tirage et 2h 4h
cinq ans betty un peu rond là bas tu as
tout cas ira jusqu'à 13,5 mais pas ma
nature soit en java du pouvoir je tort
c'est d'eux que tu peux pas faire ça à
l'époque
et ouais c'est toujours trop dur
symétrique outre les pièces un peu mieux
je vois tu vas te faire tourner tourner
tourner tourner puis un jour qu'est-ce
qu'ils ont des quatre détenus qu'ils
soient en baisse est donc largement
après moi j'aimerais bien qu'il soit
peut-être tu vois en c6 il serait bien
maintenant même les adultes femelles
commis quelques isolés ou basse et
d'entraver le parti encore techniquement
c'est moins spectaculaire que le doubs
d'agri tchouk mais peut-être qu'avec
ceux ci sur mon mieux en fait ouais je
pense qu'à royal n'aurait posé plus de
problèmes a dude avec ce style parce que
d'oudalle fin on avait senti comme
jamais contre une ariane qu'il avait un
peu de mal il avait surtout réussi à
leur bain plus on maîtrise quand bon
après c'est fou quand même la gagner
mais bon moi je dors
bref je pense tu veux aussi échanger
faire des parties reprises ces six à un
moment donné un coup tu veux garder les
dogues pourtant voilà maintenant il va
partir pour le carré lisse et 6 dont je
parlais mais mais mais moi le roi noir
est quand même très bien placé
les 5 et peut-être pas trop là peut-être
tourné là ça peut aller mais on sait que
j'adorais sa position moment semble
beaucoup plus chaotique attend qu'il y
ait des 5es et ces trois têtes sûrs à
des menaces ouais mais ça a pas vraiment
menacé et la mauvaise nouvelle c'est que
comme je l'entends pluripotentes bloqué
avec les je pense que les noirs sont
mieux et si fabien alors guy qu'il va
réussir à mettre chaque année en russie
ce qui va faire h4 mais le quai qui
revient à eux quatre et que peut-être
que guy a joué trop la sécurité qu'il
fallait valoriser ce pion des et laisser
les pions de l'autre côté tellement
compliqué ce qui en fait contrairement
au final autour de change pas c'est
moins de la fin des cavaliers a fait la
stabilité venait de partout des billets
tactique convient et tu peux beaucoup à
maîtriser le truc avec damon avant
c'était beaucoup plus et finale est plus
tactique 1 ne compte pas vous et puis
comme un malade tout le temps est ok
mais bien pour grisard sauver ça parce
que je pensais qu'il est vraiment la
perdre j'adorais la pression derniers
ont choqué il joue excellemment mais à
un moment il a dérapé
peut-être celle aux dames 5 là que ça
fait tourner le truc il appartient le
mental du change et à sentir une
structure d'options favin ouais il n'a
pas laissé souvent on la voit tu as
raison c'est la fameuse gouvernance
comparateur où ils rentrent pas dans la
grande ligne quoi maintenant c'est
devenu une tendinite sont quand même je
veux dire il n'est pas encore lancé
l'enseignant en ligne c'est une ligne
hop on avait vu dans le match keira
coeur qui va traîner
est-ce que c'est théorique ce que ça
envoie vite est ce que c'est si bien des
traits pense que les femmes dont je me
suis dit connecter les uns à dieu je
vais revenir
du coup je vois plus le parti tory honda
c'est un renault suivant appris quel
parti pris aujourd'hui je regarde du
côté d'un mondial même si je suis pour
guy tu vois je m'arrête je prends juste
le mec le mieux classé
tu vois oui contre qui
qui tombe ah bah du coup moi ça swing je
suis beau de dire les personnes arrivées
avoir flambé cette note est bon
bon première vue je dirais que les
blancs sont un peu mieux je comprend pas
du tout pourquoi mon chrono est mal
réglé à dire pas il montre 1h30 alors
que normalement je comprends pas ce qui
se passe avec le chronomètre fab
excuse moi je vais pas le mettre pour le
moment mais je suis pas je sais pas
pourquoi le colonel c'est mal à régler
parfois 24 ans des six épreuves prenant
peur ben sinon c'est quoi sinon il
reprend aussi si à chaque date le
prendre aussi s'il ya un plan simple
s'activer un petit peu après un oui bien
sûr mais bon tu prends des sites tu
viennes y est on sûr la tour à tour un
tué à l'armé blanche
je pense entre eux va maintenant bah moi
qu'il ya un truc tu as dit pas si
souvent que ça se soigne on s'est fait
dominer stratégiquement il va mettre
influencé 3 au cas où la tour en d1 il
ya le pire à cette emprise
non ce ne sont pas contre le matériel
pour un truc plus plus long terme
ceci pour ça qu'il ya beaucoup de milles
dans ces parties savaient que les gens
essaient toujours de rester en
maîtrisant l'un comme l'autre ils
prennent à elles prennent souvent les
décisions les plus les puces safe
non mais après là peut-être que je
double un truc fou pour commencer et
deuxièmement peut-être aussi qu'il a
jugé que qui est plus de chance là je
l'ordre de foot peut reposer que tourne
à la satire c'est un acquis et ce pont
d'yeu du entre deux messages e j essaie
de regarder pourra le temps parce que ça
marchait pas dans l'instant blog sauf en
attaque le plan des haies et on évite
des cadres et un sampras et 3 soit même
peut-être un jour mettra le four des 4
enfin pas trop vite un passage et patron
de fait a changé et de les contrôler
avec le pion à qui va lancer à fond mais
bon peut-être que l'on peut le faire je
sais pas non plus si on ne va pas se
presser
après sa remontée ces trois donc évident
des gars très bien il fait ce petit
blocus sur les cases noires et peut-être
deux royaumes d'euros à eux deux on sera
même d'un centre d agréables pour les
dents je pense qu est-ce que l hary fer
qui a troqué peut-être simplement ils
commencent à avancer sa petite majorité
là bas dans l'optique de taper à
certains journaux avançaient trouvions
le faire à 5 toral fouquet's est sûre d
ici sur ses pas pas forcément si on peut
faire des fautes lors des six prix ce
qui entre en inde ont passé à 6 yalta
des cinq faible auquel bien se retourner
si comme ça au passage la leçon que tv
de décathlon
[Musique]
ok on peut enfin puma régime qui te fait
ce qui se passe j'ai pas pu voir les
villes a besoin bras je pense qu'il est
mieux mais bon il faut passer mais il a
amélioré et j'ai bien aimé ce petit
manège dans et le pion à il a provoqué à
6 éliminatoires b6 c'est bien s'il ya un
échange production et plus maintenant
mais je viens c'est un peu vidé je pense
et est quoi et voilà hors jeu ouais même
sympa cette année noire exact que ça si
c'est le seul des cinq tours active
martin tu peux faire tout reprendre ici
souffrent des quatre noms ouais je suis
un avantage autant qu elle c'est la
découpe de sessegnon mailer gagnant il
faut fouiller encore la gagner mais
nathalie techer b4 tourner achats arrive
à faire trouver 8
ouais pas mal joué un bon plateau de
garder fou où je me levais un moteur
j'aurais fait défaut et 3 persos mais
j'aurais fait maintenant un peu mieux le
foot pourra faire une focale sur le
cavalry mais un jour près roi des quatre
ici ça me parait 3 des 4 6 me paraît
faire fable 3 des 4 3 tours eux deux
voilà ce que tu veux faire tour à 4 mais
bon puisque c'est son tour si j'ai pas
nourris qu'ils préférent des quatre mais
écoute c'est bien aussi mince en effet
dans les deux blocs mais je crois pas
que ça me remet il en sait trop rien ici
le projet la problématique du temps un
phare la pousse mais maintenant c'est
fini mais plus de temps pour les vents
non mais vraiment autonomes peuvent
tomber ou suffisamment abandon
égalisation fab égalisation qu'est ce
que c'est serré ses matchs de speechless
ouais non c'est pas du tout à sens
unique femme mince mais c'est beaucoup
plus agréable à suivre parce qu'il y
avait du suspense et et en plus il n'y a
pas un joueur qui fonce à baisser la
tête et à jouer n'importe quoi
honnêtement tu finisses enfoncé dans son
siège bar mais est ce vraiment c'est que
c'est trop long quand tu te fais
défoncer sénat trois heures à 12,30
partie avec rihanna sinon c'est ce que
je fais si tu me permets c'est toujours
long quand tu fais des français mais du
coup a donc donc sévèrement longtemps
que oui mais bon j'aurais quand même nom
pour celui à qui ça arrive pour les
spectateurs faisaient très différents
mais bon c'était le petit le petit
moment humour fab
oui enfin enfin du coup genre de système
ok bah du coup moins c'est parce que le
style de londres
c'est un système de londres où il a joué
avec ses 5 et il n'a pas fermé avec des
cinq jeux jouables cod rassemble et donc
voir tomber dans une sorte de structure
carlsbad alors pour l'instant depuis ses
trois pôles placés les investisseurs
excluent le four b3 aussi c'est un peu
la chance là ouais une fois qu'on
regarde qu'elle allait verser 3 pouces
et d'un jour là c'est sûr que c'est son
nom est peut-être et le cavaly on peut
peut-être quand et de pression à à 4 ou
quoi en quatre pour faire ou à croire je
pars et qui a valu à doké ici un cahier
des trois déjà toutes boissons detroit
il est bien et après ça tu verras
pioncer mort d'homme qu'est ce que c'est
que ces options être parce que saddam
par là bas je sais pas il place et qui
prend des cinq un jour aussi avec le fou
on dit qu'on verrait de tv ou que j'ai
trois griffes des trucs comme ça mais
attend il peut te faire [ __ ] g3 monf
ou g5 je sais pas car et les f4 et après
de naviguer vers détroit en ayant une
tombe bien toujours nos clients de trois
mois ce soit lui ou l'autre et j'ai pas
besoin peut-être l'allemagne 1 4 6 et 5
femmes mais juste de base je veux le pas
ce que c'est je relocalise même est ce
que tu aimes les curieuses bah ça que je
vais me restera au sein qui m'écoutent
mais ça va on attend son plan je sers la
troisième rangée sont dans le même temps
je comprends vos débuts touche option
vrai pourquoi pas s'il ya toujours eu
ces cinq 5 4 et 6 offert ex 3 pouces et
la dame barbare voilà c'est un faux
seins caf car il y avait quatre ou cinq
à la rigueur même temps le fou que tu
fais f
ça ira du waf au 5e jour de son idée bon
4 il faut au moins six nouveaux
c'est bon souvent créatif et 6000 de
mauvais quand même oser non mais c'est
vrai qu'elle est là il veut faire
cavalier f4 il menacera qu'il prend des
cinq peut-être n'ose plus est ce que tu
peux quand même faire clé des quatre et
sur high heels envoyé aux quelque 4 600
votes quoi elle fout tu vois je suis sûr
qu'ils croyaient pas trop tard mais si
tout va non mais écoute ça se met
gentiment place son attaque
ouais en fait je faire sur htc faire foi
chez 4 et à d'autres que maintenant tu
peux s'amenuiseront s'était filmé monté
la dame qui arrivait tout bon je pense
maintenant à faire du show il fut touché
c'est tout la nature affirme rachid fed
à mach 4 de mercato mais je suis d'un
match 4 et du coup ça et du coup sûr
filles en 33 matches huit matches n'est
du coup tu peux faire tous rêvent trois
tours g3 toujours amené encore un autre
ou faire du rouquin qui est gf3 tu
t'amènes quoi marrant parce que gérant
sans se fout de cases blanches et a du
mal à faire des halles aura peut-être
fou prend ainsi secrètement ouais mais
valeureux 8 et claudette fuite pas faire
f 5
si l'on voit c'est l'esprit favalli boom
f5
maintenant voilà tout à fait ce que je
voulais faire
même si on prend réussissent
intermédiaire tout reste blanche
je n'aurais pas repris ce fou quand je
le jouerai j'aurais ignorer ce cavalier
j'aurais dû renvoyer rue de poussière à
la gueule avec l'emprunt de 6 parce
qu'on fait qu'il y avait quatre kg 3
jeux
il aurait bien un f4 quand même mais on
kg 3 diffusera f5 jeudi la lui fait pas
peur jamais et kg 3 n'y a pas de 4ème et
[Musique]
ouais ça peut toujours évoquer le
quatrième mais oui on peut le dire j'ai
pas trop envie dos des citoyens et la
107e c'est bien toi
cette tour allons quand même c'est vrai
c'est chaud froid qui prendrait 5
intérêt je pense et grignoter diction ma
force options put un pion de vente qui
si paris ne tourne pas beaucoup de
choses alors c'est un choix des cinq
copains ou et 5 peut-être n'ont
peut-être pas cette juste tour un c4 ou
tour troaré des jeux pour reprendre des
quatre du poker et 8,3 des 4000 nm et d5
d'un v6 peut-être ouais c'est peut-être
pour demain je vais me roesch les axes y
voit une autre
cette dame b 6 3 des 6 très bien joué
ouais non c'était pas mal de ses
chaussettes maintenant est celle du
hatay non sur ce que les fous prend
aussi il faut prendre si ce mode que
question des huit mois attention quand
même ce qu'elle ait rodin qui menacent
donc su par dieu cet intermédiaire où il
y en a partout femme un tour des rivaux
comme quoi ab à tour des trois îles et
vu tourner un imac du couloir mais
attendait 3 il a abandonné
il a raté tour des trois y est donné
avec l'idée 1 de maths et il a fini par
craquer c'est dur de défendre un peu de
temps contre elles ressentent comme ça
tombe dessus
alors on repart pour cette même variante
troquet
rock bogueys et refonder s'impose donc
et 8 c'est juste pour libérer le pion
développement qui est quand même un peu
au dessus un fab
non il domina place mais qui ne fait pas
le trou bas tout est possible meiway
dans le dans l'ensemble un peu d un peu
mieux comme on dit que lila chess dans
le dans le championship dérider computer
des ordinateurs dans le cc cc est en
train de dominer un statut snaf mais
c'est une partie d'un pack in green
c'est une partie a déjà commandé dominé
komodo prem's qui progresse ou le temps
que la retirer mais je sais pas si c'est
une bonne nouvelle fab 1 honnêtement non
mais tu as mois voire ces ordinateurs
qui viennent de plus en plus fort ça
m'inquiète parce que j'ai l'impression
que les échecs sont quand même détérioré
depuis l'arrivée des ordinateurs 20
voies à suivre je veux dire pas à suivre
est le niveau de jeu augmente évidemment
massue c'est devenu en moins intéressant
et ça ça m'inquiète quand même ça c'est
un peu le truc dont j'ai peur c'est que
à un moment donné on arrive tu as il
progresse pour les firmes en un comme
avec la semence de plus en plus vite
je finis le jeu va pas finir le jeu mais
géré par là que jacques les prépas dans
les ouvertures c'est une insupportable
n'importe qui auras tu vois une
expertise basse et ça nos différents
soit pour un bon c'est qu'avant
[Musique]
le savoir sacré on va dire ça va des
trucs stratégique de placement de pièces
de plantes et c'est important maintenant
en fait ça ne suffit plus mais là ça
veut dire vraiment ainsi le truc devient
super force à devenir tout match en fait
les ouvertures tu vas tout de suite
passé dans leur dit il sera tout de
suite enfin tu vois oui mais qu'ont ils
sont déjà bon d'être l'auteur est encore
meilleure dans les deux ou trois mille
qua non alors il est très fort mais le
truc c'est camille n'a pas trop la
vision stratégique ça permet encore
d'avoir des nouveautés qu'on ne comprend
pas tout de suite eu à cela on comprend
pas automatiquement
il ya des financements validation se
retrouve un truc très fort ça permettra
quand tu commences tu regardes une
partie de comprendre quasiment
immédiatement tu as toi toi même plus du
tout ce petit doute est ce que leur dit
à tort ou tu vois et ce qui comprend pas
à quoi ça va tuer le dernier le dernier
frisson entre guillemets commence à
comprendre les indiennes et où enfin on
sauce tiens j'ai peur que le moment ça
va arriver sera comme tout match est
déjà là c'est devenu passer un peu moins
bien on passera un autre je comprends du
football manager on verra quoi avec la
cje à la magie du jeu est un peu un peu
en train de disparaître
j'ai peur que même après faudrait alors
très très bien beaucoup plus intéressant
c'est sûr
mais le truc en fait c'est que le fait
qu'ils terminent le je sais c'est pas
très grave en fait en soi ça paraît
toujours sur des tournois mais juste ça
augmente l'importance de la mémoire mais
je trouve que c'est le look et des vols
qui est déjà devenue trop importante
entre guillemets fap je trouve
et puis ça va mais bon je dansais garage
préfère regarder championnat de mémoire
à la rigueur cette phase est plus
intéressant - ça sert à quelque chose
dans la vie de tous les jours en plus
donc enfin tu vois moi bonjour de choc
ce travail mais non mais ok battre
faudra toujours calculer quand même et
connaître des trucs mais la mémoire ce
jour est hyper important bayrou kasparov
à sa grande époque pourquoi pas grand
maître de mémoire à mon sens dijon ça
veut dire c'est peut-être la partie du
jeu à moins excitante à jouer après que
moi mais je suis plus été qu'une grille
choco si je t'écris venu mardi où il
avait je crois que ça ira sa femme la
canaille non je le sais gibraltar chaque
bon le parle bien français et du coup je
vous dise que je poste ce repas de gala
et ce à la déprime à quoi j'ai de great
flu qui feuillette le livre pas elle m'a
raconté une anecdote we will elle est là
elle lit un livre mais que moi je fais
en tête devant mon échiquier du coup je
suis quelqu'un machin et que tu vois ça
et les mises sous sa gueule d'ange anti
nul de lire avec un livre magnifique et
et jean lui vu tu te lis ça comme ça il
y retient beaucoup mieux quand il te dis
oui mais là tu oublié ça j'avais lu ça
l'autre jour c'est juste impressionnant
je veux dire d elle l est pas mais pas
du tout bon c'est pas narratrice et les
grands malades la 25 50 ou quelque chose
comme ça et elle est pas une une nulle
quoi ah ouais enfin plutôt bon après
tout des pontons référentiel non elle
comprend deux trois trucs quand même
donc voilà je pense bien sûr c'est qu'il
entraîne du coup les paniers du tout
j'espère qu'il est bien qu'elle faisait
peine ce que roy de grosses vagues ils
je pense battu par an
ce que j'aimerais vu deux de ses marins
alors il va sacrifier ferguson qu'hier
nul ouais il va faire nul et il garde de
son point d'avancé et guy qui a une
nouvelle fois gaspillé les blancs mais
c'est important dans ce match les lions
il a fait ce qu'il a pu
il va enfin m vous-même plomb besoin
d'un joueur général un dax en gestion
mais bon tout est possible leur part dû
sacrifier un peu de temps de
développement mais je n'aurais pas été
très tentés d'aller prendre ce pion
faire la main de buzz mais bon nico tu
seras le digérer tant mieux on a eu la
partie d'avant en fait c'est une pièce
carrément mais c'est chaud de mettre en
défense
vous êtes sûrs personne pour promouvoir
tout reprend et ce qu'il veut tant faire
38 ans a quand même poussé cette aide a
pris du pew aucune je vous ferai ne
trembla thouaré semblent bons pour
corruption
tu gardes pression soit colonnes belle
campêche et des cinq mais là peut-être
plus pour longtemps on a pas mal b6 pas
ça marche c'est qu'elle n'a rien
développé que donc ouais c'est bien se
faire une place de 5e très mal se basait
1er mars
tu peux te faire ce match est
complètement ses rangs dans l'ouverture
j'ai l'impression que dans les
ouvertures qu'il a pris le dessus
donc le prendre mais si tu as envie maps
sur vous prendrez 5 qui aurait dû payer
cette nuit le pompier pas mal je sais
pas vouloir se donne quoi y'a quoi dans
matériel qualité et si tu prends le
sortir mais du coup tu menace pas
vraiment de devrait trouver ça tout à
apprendre g4 vous éclaterez demain
attendant pourquoi je ferais pas fou
j'ai simple je vais faire foucher samoa
auxquels des 6 1 6 3 qu'il faut de
précis mais je veux dire sera une très
très bonne tu as trop longs bâiller dame
à saint cloud et 2 kg tg4010 dans le
sens quelle décision prendra effet c'est
comme ça maintenant des six matchs face
à franck tu dois apprendre ce soit via
la vente a perdu mais je dire comme
attendu metal est un peu de matos il
pourrait peut-être s'acheter quelques
coups quoi font mieux que de faire
maintenant
ok bon écoute là et commence à faire un
break c'est le premier break du match ou
deux comme alias quinn temps c'est
tellement cela alors il reste encore 23
minutes et 53 secondes donc très
important les seconds et jeux pour les
gens qui sont en train de regarder il ya
le no fake un au dessus avec le
chronomètre officielle donc le no fake à
la gamme important fab toujours de
prouver le dauphin passe quelque chose
que tu mets toi c'est parti d'appoint
mais ouais
et à ceux qui à pour guérir je veux dire
s'allonge arthur et pouf espion à
développer dangereux de 500
donc bye good on a déjà vu un peu genre
de parties sauvegardées pour les mains
par fannie mae ont dû m'énerver que je
fasse h3g 4 est-ce que je dois puisqu'on
a vu on avait vu mardi à rome et même
sur le trajet simple je crois pas que la
taxe trop violente banon peuvent pas
toujours faire tout reprendre - dames
effectué huit déjà on peut simplifier
tout ça presspass deux pièces est bon
pour pourquoi guiry n'obtient rien dans
les ouvertures et à revenir n'obtient
pas ces jeux que je crois qu'en fait je
sais pas où ça va être quand il se
jouant longhi n'obtiennent jaffa c'est
plus équilibré les ouvertures la raison
que dans les speechs as tu peux prendre
le dessus dans l'ouverture c'est ça qui
m'est un tu vas tu m'intéresses bas
peut-être plus la cadence est rapide
plus fin moins de métier précis voit pas
ça c'est sûr et qui est du coup tu veux
pas complètement séché il est doigts des
petites idées en fait qu'ils ont
peut-être en vous passerez pas mais là
tu peux tenter bien c'est pas que ces
mauvaises passes et 12 mai c'est que
peut-être il a même séché les tronches à
renault +2 et franck lanoux demandent
eux aussi pas moins guéri et réduit
aussi les deux sous ce nom mais on y
envoie ici
ces beaux joueurs comme les bon ok ça
dure indien qui le plus doué qui qu'une
vaste débat c'est fort à ce que ferrer
vont presque on va ça avance un petit
peu fab
mais est ce que tu penses que contre
anne icart ou levon peut avoir confiance
mais j'ai peur dans le bullet pour mieux
vous faites le pull est c'est quand même
un truc important et on va en avait vu
d'autres fois à petit le poste depuis
mal a souri c'est pas son truc que
tomber et puis rim os lui il a pas la
rapidité d'exécution ou d'un pingouin
quoi alors par noyade je suis très
content fabregas parce que dans la
dernière arena j'ai fait 2 2 contre lui
rien dire là ambulatoire est de cinq ans
chaque les hmongs anglais de 58 500 av
c'est un jeu de ça qu'il ya le plus une
seconde mais toutes les normes ce et
empêche de tomber à la rigueur mais ça
sert que le pingouin est prenable
non mais ça gémit doute est très très
fort il unis va mais il va massacrer la
prochaine fois avec jean tu peux lui en
prendre une de temps en temps il n'est
pas imbattable
je passe vous connaissez de quoi son nom
andrew teng bingbing oui j ai mal géré
et coutumes ou des saluts genre
puisqu'il grand maître d'échecs le
tournoi est en fait il passe son temps à
faire des bulles excisées sur les 15
secondes c'est monsieur début être de sa
trente secondes de la partie avec un
seul éclair sous la barre du coup c'est
pas des échecs ça arrive tu cliques tu
cliques tu cliques a déjà les et les
bullet c'est pas des échecs mais je sais
pas quand les bulles est comme ça tu as
un peu d chacun peut pas faire n'importe
quoi totalement creux n'a qu'un second
c'est génial
le second c'est juste ridicule c'est à
dire de mouvement j'ai pris ou surprime
enfin je trouve ça complètement nom de
pierre joue à des jeux
good job à des fps s'affaisser jeu de
tir à la première personne mais comme
par exemple ceux counter strike
ouais bah tu as hâte le portail pour ça
rien peut-être mais c'est quoi le jeu la
vitesse de l'équipe est importante bien
sûr qu'il y en a plein mais on force
night par exemple mettant à plein des
jeux où la vitesse de clics est hyper
importante
demandez peut être pas je dois manger
sain qu'en faites-vous le g5 peut-être
juste 3g cette saison mais je vais faire
caler ou 4 un peu de bloquer me faire
lâcher
non du tout mais j'ai 5 après tu laisses
de cavaillon 8 kg cette tf saint ouen
mais le jour tout d'abord je fais au
quotidien si tu donnes pour gagner
quelque chose
sonaca z5 mais c'était l'avant faire
guerre faisaient rejoindre passe par un
cavalier apsys utile fait changer la
dame menaces réseau mirage cissé d'un
huit matchs tu peux te faire avoir être
comme ça aussi
non peu mieux pour le blanc ce fauteuil
ou pas bah oui tu peux faire midam sept
niveaux 8 26 dans youtube comme ça tu
vas
manquement est peut-être un peu notre
dame habitant du tout évident de 5o kg
faire dans la suite je me sais pas si
c'est joli mais tu te réactive lillois
tient les cas c'est bien ce qu'il
advient alors je sais pas quand même et
vous qu'est ce qu'on fait et c'est à
nous d'essayer de faire des 4 6 ans
aussi maintenant que cavaliers au bois
la droite dit tiens je serai là mais qui
se disent de plus en plus compétente et
d'amd 4 où je me suis offert deux
matches 8 5 eca relief 6 mais si je
n'avais pas fait du tout de suite je
suis certain que si tu veux pas me
changer les dames ferké c3 kébé 5 aussi
c'était une option
l'homme qui peut nous parler quand même
de révolution au cimetière de petits
réseaux grèce à partir de la zone euro
obsession mais je pense que ça va très
bien présent maintenant c'est inutile ça
c'est sûr je veux pas qu'on a les blancs
peuvent progresser je me bouge pas par
une pension sont nés ces histoires je
sais pas ça va partir en vrille aussi
vont plus trop de temps
non ça ce n'est pas sa femme normalement
contador n'a t'on pas ses fins et de
cinq médecins à prendre et si je
continue d'apprendre et six femmes de
vos murs ok mais ça laisse plus de ar
union qui tient de chacun et qui reprend
les blancs et vue qui pose vraiment des
vrais problèmes
geek ya vraiment un problème avec les
noirs nous de faire des recoupements
avec le 3 6 4 ouais il y avait déjà joué
deux matches je crois ces quatre sous
première dame prend bien ok il fait
juste 3 j'imagine légalise plus ou moins
on va faire ses cinq dante 7 qui avait
17 5%
ce sont pour quoi bon match à jouer un
peu comme nous quoi non mais l'adjoint
s'il te fous sorti cette fois ci punk
rock et là je pense pas loin chirac
censure et c'est ça c'est l'état de
dépenser 5 mais toujours soutenu
on demande si tu penses à starcraft
comme jeu possible je ne sais pas à quoi
tu es je crois faut cliquer très vite en
voie d'être homogènes ils font feu de
tout bois quoi ta les troupes de partout
donc peut-être c4 et b 5e h1n1
qui distingue d'abord peut-être plus
malins d'ailleurs si tu veux dire tu es
en train de faire ses cartons ça
t'arrange tu as tu fais un petit peu h6
où je suis pas ce timing et retard très
heureux comme ça tu continues sur le
même thème roger trois noms mais je
ferais bien ces quatre baies quatre mois
je ferais tempo presque ok ok mais si tu
joues ces décès des suites a enfin été
devant des changes la slave bien pour
les noirs je ne prends que l'écran de
votre engin tu ressens un stock
moi je pense que si important faut faire
gaffe ces finales ne pas se prendre le
pion pas ch
à la fin je veux le souligner parce que
parfois tu veux prendre du g5 h5 quand
même super f4 pour pour couper peut
faire un f6 et puis quand même donné
finale de roy te passer le pion en force
rachat mais c'est important de fois j'ai
déjà perdu des partis comme ça en fait
oui non mais tu peux juste oublié the
job tranche de 100 et de vie en finale
tu dis ça va bien un machin bien fait
beaucoup mais d'où sort ce qu on passe
les coupes mike glumac a des missions
f599 et g5 ya pas de chance qu avec 4,6
nous bouffe f4e et h4
donc aux bisons mais à 4 pas mal joué je
pense toujours qu'on tient acsb 5 en
général n'est peut-être de faire assène
déclin d'un premier 5 et aurait 800
d'élite way i feel adam vient jouer les
veline rares sont les 1001 probablement
famin faut pas non plus exagérer un faux
car ils laissent b2o à ce propos vous
écrivez sur tu finissais clément j
alors qu'est-ce qu'on fait bien certain
quant à la dame je vais traverser
certaines mains c'est une principe
savoir comme la dame c'est une pièce
forte d'attac tu veux ouvrir les lignes
vendre adverse deux jours alors il va
doubler sur la 7e il peut même avoir un
jour l'idée de faire football us est
sacrifiée allait faire le père pète
là-bas prépare pour ça ouais mais c'est
quand même cool surtout qui l'étude
francs du dom bien mais tu fais pas du
tout paris
c'est bien ce que je pensais c'est que
oui c'est de la merde en grand fayt non
en fait avec son g5y david hallyday avec
le plan justice peut-être ça le hockey
et la scam faut vite la lamproie
il lui défonce et sont abritées attends
tu faire geagea chevaux 8,7 faire
acheter trois échecs et passera derrière
d'exactement sept ans il briguera je
suis tellement je suis une fourrure pas
partout à prendre trois traitements pour
80 mais c'est peut-être mieux leurs
fesses d'obstacles de réfugiés hcr qui
garde un il garde au toit par un
français n'ont pas besoin faire
comprendre que c'est ce que je me suis
fait masser en force par jean retour
prend tout reprendre
même de roy h3 d'un match 2 3 et 4 dames
h4 donc tu es obligé de prendre en g3
six mois prend showdown germain
comprends c'est l'âge de vote mais ok
partie des frais qui a réglé son
problème avec les noirs tuer on en
parlait est ce que c'est en lâchant que
là que ça je pense pas à ce programme de
monstres rechute
il n'y a pas de maths c'est pas si
simple on fab peut-être un poil
optimiste sagan poste même si ça c'est
pas si sûr femmes c'est pas si sûr mon
femmes
en tout cas c'est pas si simple qui va
te mettre le feu aux anges et six autres
ff7 fou j'ai six a déjà présenté des
objets de faire rage suite les façons il
peux même te faire rompre en russie
c'est maintenant il prend soin il finit
son talent et perpètrent des blancs
avantage on peut parler c'est quoi ça
c'est parti moi j'étais tellement
persuadé que cegid cherchons voilà
devait l'être mais je sais pas très
optimiste
ah oui mais en fait non tu m'as tout du
cloître en fait puisque bien fantastique
matt de l'esc amiens par un magnifique
tour b de fable fantastique le compte de
l'even fab et ça ça brasse et un
tournage devait gagner q peur partis
donnent déjà le tarn et le tout rêve de
tourbe et de fabas et c'était un travail
d'orfèvre de la part d' aronian il fait
l'écart la fab aronian de masse
intéressant ce sont les hommes mais
après franchement des faucons il lui a
tout mis la fab aronian crois que tu
peux arrêter de chercher l'avion de la
malaysia airlines s'est il ya tout qui
rentrait fantastique belle game boy game
on a fait l'écart là il a fait l'écart
aniche en sueur ouais ben bella se fait
même star c'est dante mais du coup bah
du coup un bas du coup bien pour les
faire avec f 5 ateliers de folie annoncé
michelin et blanc
j'étais hier c'était un choix il faut
envoyer quand même un marché plutôt kiev
6 min ok tu regardais vers aussi c'est
d'entrer sur youtube 9,5 pas trop top ce
qui a le cran femmes ont déjà tout petit
mon coeur mais tu as quand même
affaiblie des classes de 4 e 5 femmes
qui voyagent compte est ce que tu penses
que le bon scénario pour anis et essayer
de survivre là en trois minutes
il reste celle de faire de fer et de
tout miser sur les bulles est à toute
façon il sera derrière bon début lot
dont c'est une certitude
il s'est quand même bien d'arrêter
l'hémorragie
alors qu'il pense pas jouer une partie
quoi être fier comme sûrs face mais 10%
mais partie en fait sont toutes reliées
les unes aux autres
oui mais tu peux prendre tu peux dire je
prends une partie après l'autre les
pièges et l'autre cas où f4 dire f4
direct à l'ebu et mon tout nouveau petit
écran dès 5 heures veillée devant des 29
lancers des semaines allez faut qu'il
faut qui sonna hachlaf qui se lâche
année je suis s'est pas cachée dans ce
match a abissé pas lâcher l'année à
contre sens ils avaient attaqué de folie
qui lui parle pas on entre dans une
position consensuelle premier match
contre contre mam est là cette saison il
a attaqué de folie et aujourd'hui je
sens timoré mais en fait le truc c'est
que oui mais comment une super attaque
et enfin services rendus berlinoise donc
là tabou le voir attaquer c'est chaud
quoi
prends un mur et j'ai commencé le match
en jouant des 4 mais en fait ça se
passait mal à parler cela mais s'est
fait dominer dans la dans la mare
occident la vieille benoni amis nul mais
il avait eu et tu vas fin oui lorsque
j'ai sur quatre va devoir essayer des
quatre quand même bien
ou peut-être partir ou peut-être partir
fab sur de l'ata castagna il sait le
faire on sait qu'on sait qui sait le
faire et il avait fait ça contre souvent
d'ailleurs et il risque de se faire
contrer mais bon ce que 128 quand cette
personne s'est noyée logique hadji 2
s'il te plaît
comment peux tu dire de telles inepties
que j'aurais aimé que vient de jouer un
coup de génie g4 et toi tu ok vas tu
veux rejouer g2 avec l'objectif de
refaire gican d'oloron bien tout est ok
on sait grâce je comprends sinon je
ferai jamais qu'est ce qu'ils racontent
fab c'est dur ta 3g de f3 enfin je sais
pas mais c'est pas ça comme athée mais
bon là c'est que les noirs ont g5
maintenant au cas où m
bon moi je dis donc pourquoi nous et de
nous faire tour f5 tous les toits forte
orages sont enfin sa forêt noire non
mais tu as et passagers du bus un petit
maurice reverdy veut quand même attaqué
tu as tu sens qu'il envie d'attaquer
mais non ces cas là lâche toi somptueux
à l'acheter coutu à ce que junior reste
il aimerait bien mais si on ne parle pas
pendant le prochain ouvrage est un nom
peut pas juste parce qu'il à tour je
pense la femme qu'on est en train de
tomber dans du moins de dix-huit là
parce que tous rêvent 5 / f katia
mais même sans ces quatre obligé je
pense juste maintenant dames 6 échelle
je vois pas trop pourquoi dans la flore
en plus trop à manger sain qui trois
balles à la dame donc 9 4 face à des
banquiers vampires du filet avec un peu
plus de jeu au pire du pian non mais
femmes
ça manque de conviction ce que failli
cela tu as cueillir à froid qui fait ce
qu'il veut
bah ouais mais bon c'est pas assez
adroit trop faible et surtout ne sera
pas en matériel la sécurité le roi jean
allaire importante des pièces lourdes
fuite du pylône et fiat depuis le nul on
est passé par ici pour faire du tort
j'ai six mois rien ne va bouger le cul
comment il peut s'en sortir aniche fab
qui j'ai l'impression qu'il est pris
dans les griffes arménienne cette partie
je vois pas comment sa seule chance
c'est que ça se passe bien il est
rassembleur physionomie du match et les
jeux dominé quoi ça me sens plus fort
que lui aujourd'hui c'est comme ça
heureusement il tapa comme coach pas
parce que s'il fallait lâché une info tu
lui dis ça enfin benghazi j'étais donc
je m'en vais pas l'enfoncer
il survit peut-être fallait-il ce bail
peut-être échanger les dames tenir la
finale sera important de prendre la nuit
mais les tours f26 peut remettre la tour
en g2 tu vois ce ré agencer après tu
fais du mali rentrent dans la finale
certains me l'ont pas aimé attend il a
peut-être la tour qui vient en des six
gymnastes tour des six tours 7
fatou rejet de tours 7
tu assures tours fc tours et 8 300
ouvrages de maths donc tu peux pas et
bien d'autres
mais les batwa aléatoire ce problème et
tout remettre à 7h et paf a blessé j'ai
remonté le moral laurent un trou soupire
où il retourne vers ses traqueurs notre
horrible il va à un faux couple euros à
la croix de grès t2 et protéger ses cinq
algérie et pratique pour retrouver
germaneau serait bien d'en mettre en
squadra première case de l'échiquier
pour l'instant bloqué mon plaisir ça
nous en donne vraiment tout sauf où elle
a tourné suis pas bien placé maintenant
tu vas tu l'auras comme une brute quoi
que tu vas des tensions entre le barrage
de piste un bel et bien et coûtent
maintenant je ne traiterai bien
partis la crème est contrée de nouvelle
fois bravache évoque le curage 3 il a
oublié où il craque
françoise il en a mis partout mais bon
y'a 4 secondes ben tu veux prime avec
l'énorme combat ce qu'ils font peut-être
qu'il veut aller aux bulles est la faire
durer plus longtemps possible s'ils sont
devenus la cadence mais devant d'autres
mais c'est pourquoi je suis est le pire
pour lui c'est qu'il boit le calice
jusqu'à la lie reste encore 30 secondes
non mais il voulait aller au bout de la
cadence sera pas je crois que ça c'est
bizarre parce que j'ai le chrono fait qu
il boit le calice jusqu'à la lie fab
kata le calice étaient d'avis et al ahly
et lui le bois jusqu'à la lie bon ok
pour femmes aiment parti une fois tu
perds pas de poids dames de plus qu sec
cussac fable le calice belle leçon de
level 1 franchement
franchement ce qu'on est en train de
voir ce soir fab
c'est vraiment une démonstration de
l'even plus fort plus fort qui est en
train de s'affirmer dans cette chasse
fab
l'année dernière il n'avait pas fait une
croix sur des connexions wiberg et qu'on
ait promis sur des prises j'ai enfin
règles de ta collection
c'est ça ma choquer commenté dr ensemble
on était un petit peu déçue de la tuque
n'est pas derrière femme qui apparaît à
part te rendrais dit oui à la belgique
de le mettre au sud non mais la femme
c'est différent non mais fable assez
différent des connexions c'est pas
penalty a pas penalty des connexions
c'est de la bcc pas c'est un joueur
blessé sur le truand fin de se tordre de
douleur tu rends pas la balle tu vas
marquer pour maintenant ça se fait un
peu mais à l'époque ça se faisait pas du
tout même utiliser pas si les mecs emule
ou quoi oui enfin bon la fusée vos
emails s'est vu les mégalithes 125 i win
avait géré la tu vas bien que décrié une
pas du temps il a perdu par des
connexions déconnexions après je sais
plus comment était la position parce
qu'on dépose jugé mieux
oui je sais mais bon chaque navette est
un connard vraiment été très énervé on
était à fond contre des pots je me
rappelle pas prête car on est tellement
souvent énervé d'un truc on aime bien ça
nous permet d'être pour quelqu'un contre
quelqu'un ça met du piment au truc
ciment alors ces petites histoires
m'écoute j'aime bien les balles encore
la bonne puisque ce plan b si cette
femme tronc c6
c'est un petit truc peut-être cavaliers
aux 5 verset 5 j'imagine savoir s'il
allait faire ses 5
ça ne va pas fort que 5 et 8 heures un
bien y'en a marre fall
ce plan tant ce site ces cinq quand même
ah oui tu peux pas y aller franco est
fier d'être fou prend un essai 5 mais
peut-être la tour en h1 va être pénible
c'est pas super bien un petit feu donc
qu'est ce que c'est j'ai trouvé qu'ils
s'en foutent bas-fonds quoi passer si le
to b 4 vous faire voir quelque part on
est fin aux deux firmes en fait même pas
échec
donc ça va vraiment à rien je garde est
maintenant un pays fier aux deux
continents soutient cette avancée si
elle est bien placée
c'est fantastique après le faire à 3,5
il faut cinq directeurs
après il prend des six semaines un bond
à 2 200 à toi déjà
enfin est ce que c'est si grave sa
deuxième col qui s'ouvre non h on s'en
fout je pense même pour mon problème
c'est plus c'est quoi
je cadre
g4 je ne comprends pas ce que ça est
très fort mais je comprends pas trop
pourquoi tu vois la colonne f tus vert d
1,4
finalement la colonnade tu penses à
menton de [ __ ] dame celle de cheveux
comme ça tu vas rentrer ses jolis seins
lévitation g4s de basket par un peu
autrement mais en fait c'est le roi noir
n'ont pu hélas mais impressionnant ce
sera elle sur un tour et fit mariama
match 7 3 6 et on sera obligé de
reprendre de la dame il y aura toujours
un taux de 9,7 pourquoi madame h7 pour
progressisme aux notes si tu verras et
fit on va me suit orange cette bouche je
sais c'est peut-être le seul coup un
pistonné
super encore toi c'est tout moi ça ne
part pas pour ça mais pas ou pour le
mode pour comprendre non non mais je
pense qu'il va peut être juste il que
l'on peut hélas il va peut-être des
gammes des cinq adaptateurs genre de
zone faisant on fait si tu bouges leroy
ta tour à vii
si tu bouges la tour comme ça la mère de
ses sept tours j'ai si ces dames et
d'amasha j'avais pas vu d'un bien du
tout du tout du tout à l adam g cette
affaire damage 5 mai lui passent tous au
carnage dame b en dames gist non mais
fab
ces deux hommes bien dans ces
magnifiques level26 impérial ce soir
phénomène bombe 1.5 c'est beaucoup trop
de choses et ça peut être en forme en
bus lot non plus c'est beau c'est que
c'est pas assez pas un ami guy en petite
forme qu'il en train de martyriser c'est
un iggy qui joue pas mal hein il est
incroyable ce soir les bonnes femmes
voilées lieu évidemment nous tue
complètement dessous non mais il est à
mon avis enfin il me fait une impression
de folie là ce soir j'ai l'impression de
retrouver la rogne and que j'avais vu à
moscou jean ferrat du monde de blitz qui
était déjà impressionnant
kiki qui était qui se battait avec les
carottes c'est nanan des compagnies à la
grande époque dhaenens était il était
dans cette ligue avec ils étaient 3,4
avec reach look mais était un petit peu
au dessus et là j'ai l'impression de
retrouver seul et vonn beaucoup trouvent
enfin petite pause aussi longue pause
mais a tout de suite mais vraiment un
beau spectacle auquel on assiste qui est
dans un autre style du spectacle de
mardi qui était qui était beau dans le
sens où le match était serré où ça se
rendaient coup pour coup
autant là on a un leeuwen alors on va en
rajouter des qu'est-ce qu'on va dire
dans un style un peu à la federer quoi
très aérien un petit peu au dessus de
tous qui balade aniche sur les quatre
coins de l'échiquier c'est beau
franchement c'est beau mais c'est un
symbole assez il ya moins de suspense
mais on n'a plus le côté tiens regarde
là bas elle atteint c'est un contre-pied
terme a dit que pour de l'autre côté je
te fais un service extérieur la main je
te jure pleine ligne c ca c c'est
fantastique on ça joue comme ça c'est
beau hein quand ça joue comme ça c'est
beau et ça m'étonnerait pas qu'ils
soient capables de faire très mal dans
ce speech est façon il va être temps de
vie final les bonnes
à moins d'un braquage en bullet ce qui
est possible messi avait pas la section
bullet même contre hikaru avec ce niveau
de jeu tout aurait été possible et samir
laurent cudi qui peut s'asseoir à la
table de levon et dire je suis meilleur
que lui
écoute à part mitroglou meilleurs
attaquants d'europe
je pense que qui a pas grand monde
aniche il va vraiment falloir qu'ils
qu'ils fassent mal enfin
il va vraiment falloir faire quelque
chose pour pour aniche
sinon ce sera fini
rapidement c'est réussit pas à se
relancer immédiatement dans le match
avec une ou deux victoires en bullet la
direccte d'entrée ça va rapidement sera
rapidement terminé les gens ben c'est
une belle c'est une très belle
performance
c'est très belle performance ce soir un
très beau match à voir le retour de fab
qui va revenir on va remettre le micro
de fa pour qu'ils puissent faire son
retour aniche
ils doivent faire quelque chose doit
sortir un il doit faire le chat le
retour physique sa niche qui doit faire
le schale c'est sa seule chance il ya
cinq points d'écart +5
s'ils marquent pas s'ils marquent pas
rapidement fab
ça va être difficile ouais c'est déjà
difficile
si gagner deux premières voilà qui s' il
va y avoir les bons mais voilà il n'ya
pas faire long feu avant on peut avoir
le frisson au cas où il gagne les deux
premières on peut avoir le frisson je
vois pas pourquoi aurions s'écroulerait
tout peut t'arriver fable c'est des
malheurs de son nom il ya le physique
qui joue il ya beaucoup de facteurs fab
tout peut arriver allez c'est reparti il
envoie des quatre aniche tu as ta le
avec des situations que je pense
démarche à tous les tours 8 l faut
scorer fans et que tu vas faire même
planche a bien marché ok ce pays joue
peu avec 3 des fois ça
passer des trucs sur un trône et manger
tu vois ce qui fait le plein de changer
de case doit prendre du taureau trois
tours h3 quoi lors des trois tours age
iii qui va le sortir pour ça c'est sûr
après les noirs par contre qu'ils ont pu
te faire des trucs genre y mettre le
client c'est ça qu'ils sont de 5 et 6
qui étaient contre bâle a pris des
chemins
je pensais qu'il voulait juste aller de
l'attaqué non pas du tout je pense qu'il
ya une erreur sur le chrono parce qu'il
met déjà quatre minutes de passer fab
femmes bac alors ça et le crotoy
frontalement à tanger césar par 13 5 et
6 arrière une erreur sur le chrono fabia
je veux croire bon je vois pas en faute
la diffusion vu qu'il ya un problème il
ya il reste 29 1040 c'est pas possible
il n'y a pas eu vingt secondes de jeu là
les mots qui arrose et que vous
souhaitez les bars les sessions l'aïki
du cursus obligé enfin tu es super
non mais francfort cède pas contredit
c'est tout à fait normal de casser une
télé pour ça quoi de plus naturel et
normal quoi
barry une réaction très saine marc même
genre sont des maïs 88 faire aronian qui
est mal autant un fab aléas niche il
faut scorer fable pour pour le pour le
piment l'apport le plan allait fab est
ce que tu as dit à la mi-temps à nice la
pente est parti qu'est ce que quand tu
l'as eu là tu as dit quoi avec un coach
crise avec un coach comme toi là je ne
sais pas comment enfin comment faire
enfin tu vas y tu ne seconde pas très
bien ok donc sinon je ne sais pas ce que
c'est ce qui va faire un métier bon
juste je vous disais bien quoi au moins
un premier constat il joue vite et bien
toujours très bon accueil qui va
rebondir vers aux cinq fab aller à nice
ça qui est bien l'udc ne veut gagner h55
mais la gagnante est peut-être c'est
vrai mais il ya deux pions
il ya plus rien 5 qui retombe fab mais
qui sont ces 4
c'est dur seniors mais allez allez à
quelles épreuves cette année ça y est il
à la fourchette femme elle est la faute
d'alliés le fou qui tourne sans ketchup
c'est bon allez bosser 6-2 au plus des
renoncements si peu c'est le mec est un
guerrier tv5 à y aller c'est bon allez
plus que quatre points d'écart face tout
peut arriver tout peut arriver dans ce
match va encore rester bien là ah ouais
mais bon là si tu re scor fab derrière
on revient à +3 tout est possible allez
il a changé de variantes
enfin j'ai envie de te dire fab mais
c'est les bonnes qu'elles changeraient
by vince et les bonnes mais enfin quand
même on dit quand même la même chose ils
jouent sans grande cause
attendu avec petit rock la scène ah les
femmes les jeunes qui est un peu tu vas
qui est un peu en surchauffe il a du mal
à la souris
raymond tu joues avec la souris il faut
changer de surface vers cette voie c'est
ça fait partie du jeu c'est un facteur
aller jusqu'à une autre génération
faut-il le souligner fab levon est plus
plus âgés l'allemagne a plus dans mon
agenda n'ont plus le choix
et disons non donc c'est plus une
génération ordinateur et quand même il
meurt ce sens gamer qui est bien avec
l'annoncé du hce peut-être faire 6 5 un
jour on va voir maintenant les blancs
6-2 donc de lutter contre les saints
qu'il y arrive à une amie la dame son
centre ailier mais je sais pas si on va
y avait longtemps avant peut-être quand
il n'y a pas de raison à les décaler
faire qu'il y ait des vingt sept 27
tours 8 et qui a aidé sat du coude que
des fonds de tomber 6 mai à ses options
ces deux mais bon il protégeait sur fait
de connecter comme d'avoir une jolie
[Musique]
les bons certes pas mal jouèrent
peut-être rien c'est bien ce qui est en
train de faire les bonnes mais attention
quand même parce que c'est fou et ça ce
sont rois
kappa foot français demain en est un qui
peut s'asseoir à la table de 9 ans il
est parti pour cela quand même super de
foot en plus c'est autre chose c'est que
ça reste un petit coup bon boulot pertes
d'eau dessus tortue tu archi dominé le
match et puis surtout on sait que c'est
ton point faible
le bullet et tu te fais tout de suite
tapé bas mais hugo aussi crise au 8 mai
on soit pas dans sa manche on sent
monter après un petit déjeuner quand
j'ai eu d'yeux microsoft qui n'a plus
d'échecs mg est allé fab trois points
d'écart belges ou les choses comme ça et
l'algorithme en sueur l'algorithme ans
sur la grecque qui pensaient que c'était
les vents qui allait prendre le dessus
en bullet et où baby de ce retour
immédiat en fin de tour par ainsi si tu
ne fais pas de tours 8
j'attends ce six normales
tu veux faire un prêt de ce match qui
est en train de tourner fall way we will
paraît évidemment c'est chez pour geek
ça se passe comme ça est monté à 3
points d'avancé quand même pas faire un
nom mais il reste qu'il reste longtemps
femmes les parties ont pas été très
longue un nom à la hausse touchant leur
nom mais coûte finalement tant mieux
pour le suspense que diable il ya
peut-être une minute d'écart il ya mon
avis reste encore 23 minutes trente de
jeu à peu près fab je peux pas trouver
de nos fake mais y'a papillon 3,5 là
avec le fou bessette qui reste en prise
derrière
ouais mais le pion le pion va pas tomber
5 je sais pas
bon les bons qui est quand même en
contrôle qui joue pas mal je m'emballe
un peu femme écoute on va voir bien joué
de la part de les bonnes ce qui est venu
s'en prendre aux pions des cinq dont
centrale important de 5,9 à ben c'est le
festival tactique il a lancé trois pour
prendre 5 hockey n'est fait dans ce sens
oui mais c'est mieux son sens conway
mais je pense qu'il a réagi mais la
position halliche
ouais parce que tu as puis on s'est
passé mais qui a le courage qui leur
loue g4 jusqu'à qui peut s'asseoir à la
table d'aniche fab attends attends c'est
s'échauffent parce que ça va aller faire
sa valise avait taquiné par derrière
j'ai ton juste trois mois d'âme des uns
et des machins matin
du coup la tête mais n'y a pas de
victoire bonnot jeux de clans s'est fait
contre est actif y heleven fantastique
les bonnes
meilleure attaque d'europe coup dur pour
bien que c'est un petit coup dur mais
fabry en effet il 20 ans on voit qu'il
veut c'est sa meilleure présence tout
cas ils étaient dominés de partout pas
encore en cinq minutes il ya un poil
dominé mais il tenait le score trois
minutes par contre était là le festival
andré son plein nous refaire son machin
tout cas c'est un très beau match une
nouvelle fois femmes auxquelles on
assiste et rien n'est fait il reste
encore 20 me de match 24 points 4 points
ils restent y reste au minimum 4
il reste minimum on va dire cette
adresse ou moins cette partie je pense
si cette partie sachant que qui a
peut-être un peu de temps d'écart fabien
si cette partie quatre points d'écart
il a encore un joker grillé il aura
passé ne compte évidemment
il faut scorer tout de suite pour aniche
rappelle toi un doute avec deux points
de retard à six minutes de la fin et il
a gagné le match donc ça peut aller vite
hein ça peut aller très vite fable les
vannes en plus ce qui est toujours un
petit peu en difficulté autant et c'est
vrai que sa main qui atteint dans un
match contre oui dans une demi-finale
contre les vols de données votre
encontre
mokssit monica wons contre maxime déjà
je pense que c'est la chanteuse à total
mais compte ricardo c'est encore pire
oui c'est un gros problème autour du cou
10 kg il peut lutter de vin est la
maxime en plus je sens que c'est un
séducteur données mises bas il peut il
peut pas si bastian et wiba hikaru et
maxime c'est cette année oui je viens
les échecs surtout chez 3 c'est quoi
l'idée fasse ça m'échappe kg gardes tu
penses que ça tient debout il ya ma
tondeuse et un matin pour jets 3 je ne
serai pas en fait ce qui se passait je
sais pas j'ai déjà vu qu'avec les trois
ce qu'ils pensaient comme toi en fait
bon je fais ma danse parle oui mais je
pense qu'il a besoin c'est renault bon
du coup et patronaux et une maj
chauffeurs des bus qui ont fait ça va si
les ongles est longue et tout de suite
mais du coup le coup de grâce si vous
comptez 5 points d'avance gras c'est
plutôt les parfums femmes pardon grasset
plutôt les parfums j'ai des grassois
nantes à dix coups de grâce à un ami
ouais fragonard tout ça lui retombe dans
une structure un petit peu cheap
denis 1 mondial d'envié bienvenue au
caire écoute moi j'en joue souvent des
trucs comme ça non mais tu ne fais que
ça mais guérit que ramon vraiment pas
réussi à installer son jeu l'écaillage
de fraude au machin le stopper quand vas
tu as du mal ou pas tant la tête marc va
pas trop à une place à prendre
voilà tu fais rien mais tu prendrais un
truc dont je garde cette envie tu vas
jouer pour faire à 5 e tour brillant
avocat
bon vous avez vous accueilli la tronche
mais s'il peut la seule chance pratique
je te mettre à quai à angers 3 mais je
préfère qu'on a compris ce grand chose
objectivement en 80 parties mieux que de
faire à long terme d'un match 8 4 mais
tout ça quand même c'était complètement
ça l'est pas pour ses sacs belle analyse
femme ne doit pas non mais tu vas
regarde ça peut pas marcher en asie
comme lui ça ne marche pas du tout
entier prendra mhkd à voir donc
non mais c'était marrant il est dommage
qu'elle ne soit pas notre surprise à
leur ex dames des mondiaux je suis sur
stocks et donc aux dirigeants une
feuille iris ou quoi c'est tendu un mail
à six points d'écart
je pense que les vannes 1 0 trop cuite
est en train de marcher sur sur la prod
chez sting meilleurs joueurs d'europe
est-ce que jude a peu parlé à les bonnes
je pense que les vannes fait une
prestation plus impressionnante encore
que la prestation de de duda qui était
déjà une prestation majuscule mais là je
crois que ce soir les veines est en
train de se surpasser mais duda le truc
si on était sûr que si on ne connaît pas
on le voit pas à jouer comme souvent des
gros joueurs comme ça et ce n'est pas
les tops commun pour l'instant et donc
on l'imaginé mal à résister au temps
il ya peut-être un pur produit 6 mi
temps reprend g6 tauromachie c'est
dommage ça tu es devant louis louga
aussi tout le côté on découvre ce joueur
il y tient tête même plus du coup il a
battu gay juke est donc cette baisse
correspond est ce qu'on doit l'arrêter
le match parce que guy est en train de
ramper alès de niveau 5 milles est-ce
qu'on n'est pas en train de mettre en
danger la santé des joueurs famille en
continuant ce match là on the price of
speech ce qui en fait quand c'est fini
ça continue messi est ce qui aurait pas
fab à ton avis une commotion cérébrale
ou quelque chose là dessus et ce qu'il
faut pas aller voir le docteur es tu
accélères un peu comme au rugby la
correction pro de locomotion tu prends
tu prends dix minutes tu vas tu vas voir
ce qui se passe voilà il n'en peut plus
ne faisons aucune joseph cynisme nom
barris bouffer sinon mais là tu espères
que ça se finisse intel a dû tu en as
marre enfin le ton est même assez
nombreux ce soir sont encore 750 mais
sans la première page on n'a pas eu de
l'algorithme nous a pas ne nous
appartient pas une loterie
on n'a pas gagné à la loterie de
l'algorithme on est quand même 750 donc
l'incident tous de suivre avec nous
c'est quand même sympa mal double tour
aura trois ou jeu quoi d'autre mieux
guillaume blot c5
les capacités question sera pris comme
ça
voilà c'est très bien tu vois c'est de
ça dont je parlais au début c'est ton
but un peu avec les marcs d'or ce genre
de finale et que crever les fous dans le
mental et cases noires après la jolie et
ab4 faible atteindra que c'est bien
c'est 4 mai bordeaux voudra peut-être
plus en plus en vente aura cinq baies 5
mais bon tu te fixes dire comme un coin
mais oui je l'activité à la place même
show met d'accord par des quatre simples
de chez en éruption pas encaissé d'essai
c'est un coup d'oeil rien n'a rien et
puis on en est le roi me touré six
patients
d'ailleurs pas possible de qualité mais
le dire en somme c'est impossible je
trouve que leur droite sont importants
mais chez elle lui faudra de jetons la
bouffonnerie
il y avait reversé attend peut-être la
chance les espaces fidèlement leur fais
tienne tu l'avais lâché des cinq patrons
voilà c'est une manie j'étais en train
de mettre une certaine pression du match
et 4 et h5 de faire [ __ ] de notre
mieux ok sinon il fait un échec deux
échecs croit trop de choc des quatre qui
saute je pense à autre des deux mais je
pense qu'il y avait un nouveau dès
samedi matin et tu t'écoutes l'europe
pour h4 leur dernière je suis titulaire
en d4
il se bat bec et ongles j'adore ces
expressions 21h à tomber saison à
tourner normalement malgré tes baskets
et ongle soit depuis le traçage des
ventes est quand même sacrément québec
et les ombres de partout mais c'est vrai
moi c'est si seuls à tour est mal placée
seul compte auquel aniche fait quand
même plaisir qu'ils ont regagné une
femme oui peaufinant les as cosmique
mais mais bon cette partie qui tu vois
où il était gagnant qu'il a perdu et ce
que est ce que c'est mais pour nous
c'est le dernier tournant ce we will et
non mais un fait auquel votre bail à
kemp à 2 ou 3 août à tout petit il ya eu
2 2 pins de tournant une domination
générale de les vannes et ya eu les deux
parties celle avec la dame de plus et
l'autre en bullet qui ont scellé le
match
sans ces deux brouillé fait c'est une
over les vannes aurait quand même été
devant à ce moment du match mais le maïs
ou du show mais bon c'est mérité mais
plus de baume au coeur du couperet pour
les autres article extrait à prendre le
baume du tigre des baumes de titres de
partout pas
mais bon match bon match beau match un
très bon match non fait des déchets
d'heure parce que rien ne s'était passé
techniques souvent mais mais quelques
trolls parti il a su montrer des chèques
offensif aussi le camp des bulls adac
costaud il a montré aux est très costaud
femme très costaud xxl xxl même après
mais cette relative faiblesse en bullet
froid qui sera pas favori ou n'importe
quelle demande me met en rage
intéressante quoi qu'il en soit n'a
apprécié après quand même l'impression
que maxime icart où c'est quand même
encore encore un cran au-dessus fab mon
nom mais ok je suis le point de celui là
surtout chance magnifique une nouvelle
fois s'en sortent pas mal de votre cours
des caisses de là-bas
après il est pas spécialement mieux
j'imagine que les blancs ont pas mal de
contre jeu il va essayer de faire tour
c'est un tour c'est 8 allée matin en
force
une fois un déficit sur elle
ça reste ça reste très compliquée voilà
certaines faiblesses de 7 pour le
fabriquer je prends pour se situer sur
paname premier de la tour ses limites en
train de te faire un feu fixé une
nouvelle fois à pas sûr non maîtrise
mais c'est vite et c'est vraiment un
tour d'essai
j'étais moins bien oui oui passer
tellement peu plus faible après ça se
tenir et ce après sa décision de prendre
le plus six mais tu te fais tourner deux
nuls ou g400 les veines il a intérêt à
un petit peu la jouer elle même cette
histoire de temps je sais pas si mal
timide mathématiquement c'est déjà gagné
mais il n'est pas forcément courant du
temps qui reste donc tu as y joue une ou
deux minutes de plus we thought prix
pouvoir des partenaires - c'est toujours
du c'est tout bénef 1 surtout que c'est
lui qui pressent un bon il ya quand même
des nations unies resteront après bleus
vont jouer davantage depuis deux mois ça
m'a plombé n'y a plus et puis la tour du
coa pas pu intervenir et venir après si
d'investir un point ce qui finit par la
paire mais le jeu de revenus que 3 des 5
2 et puis surtout que c'est l'inversé
les l'apathie gagnant mais bon de base
n'était pas censé y ait des cinq années
d'option non mais j'en repars avec en
gros tu joues deux minutes une fin on va
dire que c'est même c'était juste une
partie tu peux la gagner tu peut la
perdre mais il leur
après c'est encore la gagne oui seconde
argos livrent certains trucs ça va vite
en fait un même même quand truc c'est
qu'avec la seconde de plus quand tu
enchaînes les coutures à y songer au 77e
ça ça fait vite du temps quoi 3,4 mais
le petit temps du lag il ya le machin
sculptures et cantal quand tu écoutes a
peut-être encore un dixième de seconde
qu'on compte pas tu vois le temps du
serveur le machin c'est ya passé en vf 2
ans et 3 maintenant et passe de l'autre
côté
ben ouais c'est beau il va lui refaire
un lucerne 17
c'est plutôt re 5 magnifiques un bâti
sur le statut pro nelson bref voici
qu'il a eu et il a consommé deux minutes
et encore marqué le point non mais c'est
comme de presse il reste 7 minutes fab
dans le sur le compteur of sur le chrono
officiel mais on a toujours ce ce petit
doute si tu veux massacre à la
tronçonneuse geek il va devoir quand
même repartir à ses études s'il veut
faire face à des joueurs de ce niveau la
fab on voit encore l'écart qui le sépare
fabien non mais tu vas encore l'écart
qui le sépare face au gratin du top
mondial va pas je sais pas à quel point
son ex-belle-soeur grioo com entre les
moins bons que karajan je peux te le
dire non mais c'est pas un mauvais
blitzer c'est pas comme caruana carole à
suivre on savait que c'était pas c'est
pas le nom s'est passé depuis celui de
sa spécialité guéri c'est c'est un bide
soeur
c'est un bosseur correct amel est bon
c'est quand il joue comme ça il est
peut-être fallait pas grand monde qui
peut lui parler un nom
c'est ouais tu prends deux peut-être tu
tombes mais la structure est l'erreur
c'est 3f si c'est tout bon pai a eu
l'idée sur b3 tour prend b3 tu prends
prend un écu passé le pion à l'option
adam
c'était joli donc tu coûtes et mieux
avec les noirs pour eux trois je pense
je sois parti sur la partie vers 3 tu
vois toi cas d'échec ma tournée ici soit
tu repars en biens un galion c'est ça
qui est tellement fort de 11
mon job il ya peut-être prendre la news
qui sait pas comment progresser vraiment
pas de nulle part jamais l'automatique
toi comment tu vois si je veux faire
tour à 3 6 3 son argué me faire tour b1
et les bécistes aller
alan kay s'assurant ferme je pense quand
même joué autant tourner ah ouais sur
les deux parties live
il fait tourner du temps ce que ça joue
sajou ou sajoo champions et que cinq
plus tard
non on vous ils bâclent tourné comme un
idiot pas ils essayent en plus d'avoir
mangé la outre le fait soit bien
stratégiquement de nos scores tu veux
faire mon chrono ni presse les positions
ben sasson c'est mathématiquement gagné
il ya plus de suspense mais mais bon il
a quand même tourné encore on sait
encore jouer à plus de deux minutes
maximum à 5 minutes maximum donc maximum
dans deux parties comme sa fille avec m
ouais puis 7 c'est quand même gros seins
nus non c'est quand même c'est quand
même gros alors que le prochain match
fab
ce sera le combien le neuf non je crois
que c'est 9 octobre avec la fiche la
moins alléchante finalement de ces
quarts de finale
visite sow qu'on suivra avec toi fab les
y invite du coup ce que ça donne vous
avez vu ta position après il est
probablement très mauvaise forme et
ensuite on aura le match en ratant je
vais dire leur ce sera le 11 octobre
on en reparlera mais je vais voir leur
noter quelque part le fameux le match à
ne pas rater hikaru nakamura contre
maxime vachier lagrave c'est vraiment le
choc des quarts de finale c'est
quasiment une finale avant l'heure fabre
c
les deux meilleurs la présence sont les
deux favoris du tournoi et
quiconque ils ont déçu c'est de ce quart
de finale qui aura des allures de finale
parce que celui qui le gagne on sera
quand même bien bien bien partie femme
pour aller au bout un oui nathan hale et
venant domine mais bon l'autre partie de
tableau est plus faible
l'art et auradou das enfin normalement
de vieilles saut mais non c'est très
bien mais jardin ou de maximiser ce sera
jeudi aux fab à partir de 19 heures
match à ne pas manquer heureusement j'ai
3 mai puis basta c'est long pour ces
l'on pourra niche mais normalement c'est
la dernière femme dernier roman dernier
+8 ça fait mal hein ce match aller faire
des ruines à la fin pour finir en beauté
pour aniche avec le paradou la ruine
sous une robe
dommage dommage dommage grave imagine le
match incroyable et un final un doodle
evans très calme étonnant maintenant n'y
crois pas trop mais hautement qui aura
10 au début on n'y est pas du tout en
fait tu aurais dis ça en fait ça ne va
pas arriver donc enfin fou et j'en ai
tout à fait raison ils n'ont pas dit
d'ailleurs tiré la cote team et un tour
guidé que tu craques avec ce type de
match tu t'es fondre un mais j'aurais
juste faire remarquer que en fait tout
le match d'hier il a plutôt été
forcément ouais il était il était tout
le temps à la rupture au rupteur comme
ulysse et aux vélos sauf quand tu tiens
de justesse dans un groupe plutôt
accrocheur ou quoi s'accrocher à la roue
de l'even et finalement abandonnée il a
explosé
c'est un peu salace et un peu tes le
système de l'explosion quoi tu lui
donnes roule en renault
là mais c'est le truc aussi c'est ça
c'est tout les bars sont liés si tu fait
souffrir le maca défend différence
défend machin tu oses ou 4 mais bon boum
quand même fait un jour tu t'en fous tu
finir en beauté avec un sacrifice les
qualités c'est de la merde tu sers à
rien tu te tue le corse 2b 3 228 francs
cfa 3 salles curan ce tour prend 1,3
même ça marche bien devoir rectifier ou
tour prend 1,3 à jour pour nous on
aurait fait tempo rhin et demain soir à
21h
toi aussi tu une petit à petit tu as je
comprends tu vas comprendre et donc
demain 21 21h à l'aréna vendredi favand
cinq minutes donc mon je verrai ce que
je fais je vais envie de faire un défi
comme je ne suis pas intéressé par les
cinq minutes
moi je n'utiliserai que trois minutes
samantha burke malheureux sinon j'aurais
fait ça tout le temps fait ça ne
m'intéressait pas il ya ptet ya quelques
punchline qui sont prêtes à vous dont
une qui est vraiment un petit peu
violente et bon femme que faire un je
suis obligée non bah c'est quoi ces deux
années de violences c'est de la violence
pure et ont des études a mis en relief
en fait ou pas du tout l'ancien nom mais
je mérite mieux être et samedi je pense
c'est une vidéo bonus ua celio pas tous
les deux jours ignorant entre tu as
c'est ce soit il faut bien comprendre
que les vidéos entre ce sont vraiment
les vidéos bonus quoi ça va être dur
pour les bons pour de l'état de seconde
alors visqueux alors je sais pas fameux
d'après le chrono que j'ai oui et je
pense que de toute façon ils sont pas
les à s'embêter à sa série 5 secondes de
plus ou pas le match est terminé on
attend autant
de 7 points depuis la can gagnée la
portion des débuts est dynamique il a
dominé de la tête et des épaules du
début à la fin sans jamais baisser le
niveau c'était un genre de de bois
constrictor qu'il a pris la proie guiry
et dirige et qui s'est fait exploser qua
non avant relève à notre beau match très
bien je lançais ball à partir des quarts
de finale c'est bof av mais faudrait tu
vois un premier tour avec je sais pas
moi d duda des le coin guillem denaro
dit ski qui se joue un peu entre eux et
qui arrive tu vois avec seulement 28 qui
viennent dans le tableau final vraiment
la fin quoi sinon ils n'ont pas le
niveau quoi normalement mais on l'a bien
vu
bien vu les andriatiana les machins ça
tu as et avait pas de preuve c'est que
des très bons joueurs mais l'autre face
au monstre n'existe plus non non non et
duda qui était surprenant et normalement
ça il aurait dû se faire ce match et peu
à part car yakine mais où est la reina
king shaka leur sera à 21h lundi et
vendredi alors sera pas jouer tous les
lundis et tous les vendredis mais bon là
pour la peine sera vendredi
bon ben c'est nickel non mais écoutez on
se dit à bientôt je sais pas sur la
chaîne sûrement du stream vidéo est
pourri le 9 octobre 1 pour le prochain
match que bon tu as maintenant visite il
peut peut-être surprendre s'auto-exclure
fin mais on n'est plus à l'abri on n'est
plus à l'abri de rien on épure à
briderait merci de ton ton salut
chaleureux